e e
good morning if you could please join me
for the Pledge of
Allegiance I pled
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the for stand One Nation
God indivisible with liberty and justice
for
all that I open the public hearing on
House Bill 146 and invite the prime
sponsor to introduce his bill
thank you Mr chair and the members of
the committee and also let me thank you
for changing the date unfortunately I
wasn't around the week that was
originally scheduled and I certainly
appreciate that the time I was going to
bring some donuts but then I realized
you can't have food in the committee
room
so that problem solved yes
[Laughter]
right yeah but I know you're not a
police officer
there you go Firefighters eat donuts
too anyway uh uh for the record uh Jack
Flanigan uh represent Hillsboro 45 which
is a florial of four towns that would be
the towns of Hollis Brookline Mason and
Greenville quite large
geographically um the building you have
in front of you was uh generated because
of a con uh constituent issue um he got
a moving violation state trooper had
pulled him over he was with his Down
syndrome son and alleged uh
speeding um what happened was he uh
disputed the claim sent it in within the
30-day window that you had uh to dispute
the
claim emphasis on 30 days to put it in
the dispute and then he waited uh for
the um the court to assign a
date now the issue that uh the
constituent had was that the state
trooper was riding the back of his car
like road rage his behavior was out of
control and uh he wanted to use the uh
video camera as evidence for the
behavior and the conduct of the
officer the
um so he complied within the 14-day
window of the date for a discovery
request but then when he asked for the
videotape
he was instructed that they don't keep
the videotape past 30
days so literally the
videotape which is a is a culpable
evidence basically is destroyed even
before he might have the chance to ask
for a hearing and then on top of that if
he did get a hearing it's well past the
30 days for him to receive the evidence
that would be helped prove his case
uh I'm just looking at my notes bear
with
me the um so the issue really here is
his
rights were basically because of this
policy the state police have were
trampled because he could not present
his case and prove his case um I have
notes here but I can't even read my own
handwriting
so
umed only those help oh the other thing
too is and and I'm not I I a former
brother-in-law was a State Trooper but
um my gut feel is that if the videotape
absolutely proved the sincerity of
sincerity the the seriousness of the
claim that tape would be kept other
words they would have taken upon
themselves to keep it so I don't
understand how a person who was trying
to defend themselves wouldn't have
access to the same video camera past the
30 days and all I remember what that
note was is that the way the system
works is after 30 days they get rid of
the
tape and my thought process was okay
hold everything till the 30 days and if
you receive notice of the request for
the hearing keep only those in the cloud
where they keep the videos now so in
other words it's not like not a massive
amount of recording being saved it's
only specific to the ones that they're
disputing as it relates to the validity
of the claim did that make sense it does
and I I'm pretty sure they already have
a process for criminal cases so it may
be just happening a mirror of that but
we'll find out when we talk to it I'm
sure they'll come up and say the other
but I guess the issue here is fairness
and the uh the exculpatory evidence you
know it is truly part of his defense and
if it was a much serious claim and I
will tell you uh to digress this a
little bit is that the judge realized
when he got into court realized that
there was a problem but there was
nothing no legal precedent that he could
use that would basically throw it out
because of failure to provide Discovery
but what he did do was he reduced the
penalty the monetary penalty knowing
that now he's relying upon basically the
uh the statements of the the trooper
which they have to abide by because
they're officers of the Court
um but it still didn't allow the
constituent to present his his side of
the story and I think it's totally
wrong thank you anyone you have any
questions representative rhs thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you for taking my
question so uh we did open up the the
public hearing when it was originally
scheduled and of course as you know um
it was continued but we did hear um that
the info is required for three years if
there is a court hearing and the concern
was going to be having different time
frames for different
circumstances would CA would just cause
overall confusion for the public and for
the Departments do you what would you um
I guess what would be your your thought
on that or how to solve that sure I'm a
little I'm a little confused and I'm not
avoiding your question so when you say
different time frames meaning each crime
has a different time frame for retaining
the the the
information so if if I may Mr chairman
um so we heard from the uh the the
assistant district attorney I believe
from marac and said that there would be
confusion with multiple time frames um
charges often time reduced so if my
understanding like the chairman was
saying if it's a if it's a criminal
charge that that time frame is I don't
even know what the time frame is um but
they also said that if if the if the
case is going to court it has to be held
for 3 years right so then but if this
was not like so you asked for it to be
held
the third like you're saying that was 30
days so there's a standard 30 days which
it sounds like it was held for that
amount of time so if there's different
time frames if there's different time
frames because they're they're also
thinking the cost right for for the
downloads in the storage is you know
exponential for for all that charges so
that was the concern that the attorneys
have and the different agencies have so
I was just curious if you had a thought
of how that could be handled I'm still
still a little confused on your question
representative because you might just
it's okay you might not but I want to
answer your question I don't want to
ever not answer your question I think
what what what if I may she may be
saying is that so you have the criminal
cases they have to hold these for a
certain amount of time sure for a civil
case like this it would almost be a a
rolling type of thing because you'd have
some cases where you'd have it you know
30 days from this day next month you got
four so then having to keep track of all
those dates I'm not sure how they would
do that knowing how long to keep each
one when to destroy it I'm not sure I'll
have to ask them really if if I
understand the question and I my my
initial response
is I think the person's rights
regardless of the severity of the issue
should be maintained regardless of the
of of the crime itself in other words
the process needs to accommodate
everyone and everybody should have that
same right whether it's just a violation
for Speed or in fact you know they pull
them over and there's 30 heads in the in
the in the the trunk of the car right I
mean you can't just say well this crime
has or this violation has only this
duration for the video because the
person had 30 days he fell within the
parameters of the process that is he
disputed it okay but the evidence was no
longer there and I think that's wrong
just
fundamentally I hope I answered your
question regardless of the time frames
yeah um I tend to I tend I tend to agree
because I I'm just made me think of
something if if that citizen had got out
and struck the officer and now was
captured on the tape that tape would
still be there oh bet you bet so the
fact that it would benefit the citizen
um that's not there so yeah I'm going to
look into that thank you thank you see
you no further questions thank you thank
you very much and again Mr chairman
thank you for allowing this to go the
extra week I certainly appreciate it yep
um chair calls major Davey
good morning ladies and gentlemen of the
committee thank you for hearing me my
name is Brendan Davey I'm a major in
charge of the operations Bureau with New
Hampshire State Police I am here today
to testify in opposition to this uh
piece of proposed
legislation uh I will uh point back to
assistant Marat County attorney Steve
andress's uh testimony last week uh when
this hearing was initially scheduled uh
he made several good points including
that uh if this law were to take effect
that it would be to
uh require that certain evidence be
treated differently than other evidence
in terms of the standard for Discovery
it would also serve as a mean means by
which to disincentivize agencies that
don't currently have body warn or
cruiser videos uh from engaging in their
use because they wouldn't want to take
on the headache of the of that disperate
treatment of one type of evidence versus
another type of evidence um as I wasn't
here that day could you just summarize
for me what that testimony was with
regard to types of evidence yes sir um
specifically in the in this proposed
piece of legislation that recordings um
made of Motor Vehicle violations for
which a summons was issued would be
required to be turned over to the defend
uh to the defendant within five days of
any request therefore which is to set a
different legal standard for that
evidence as compared with all the other
evidence that would become a part of
Discovery in any normal case so if it
matched would there be a problem um if
it matched there would not be a problem
and in fact there isn't a problem
because it does in fact match um the law
on body War cameras provides for the
retention of video for no less than 30
days and up to um very very high limits
as a matter of fact in the State Police
based on the classification of a video
that we have in our system um many of
them are a hundred years yeah um because
of civil uh liability and the uh statute
of limitations there on even those cases
that excuse me we suspect or have reason
to suspect are going to be part of civil
litigation our our minimum for those is
four years uh when it comes to a normal
everyday um unremarkable we'll say
traffic stop whether it's a warning or
summons uh 30 days is our
minimum whenever we get a
complaint that um our Troopers have been
discourteous otherwise unprofessional or
behaved in an unlawful fashion then
those videos are saved and their
retention period is significant so that
we have all the opportunity to um refer
to them in any litigation that might
come whether it be a civil lawsuit or
otherwise
so
uh what already is in place is uh a
balance that is governmental efficiency
of operations on the one hand and
constitutional rights or the ability to
make complaints about professional
behavior and Our obligation to provide
professional Behavior to our
constituents
um as far as the the notion that in the
case that spurned this piece of
legislation um the the defendant's
constitutional rights were Abridged I
would only answer that by saying the the
defendant was in court for an allegation
that he violated the law by speeding um
the case that another vehicle
in this case allegedly driven by a New
Hampshire state trooper and allegedly
far too closely to the defendant um is
not necessarily and directly material or
evidentiary as far as the defendant's
speeding that said we have an interest
in knowing about it all the same and I
would argue that had the defendant in
the case that allegedly spurned this
piece of
legislation called and complained and
said look I I got pinched for Speed but
the only reason was because I had a
vehicle
uh almost touching my rear bumper and it
was driven by one of your Troopers well
then we would have looked into that um
so uh all that to say that generally
speaking the uh the circumstance which
leads to this uh proposed legislation is
pretty unusual um and certainly not a
part of our design but the law as it
stands um Works fairly well there is in
Senate Bill
289 uh some work on the body warrn
camera
um standard in RSA 105 D2 uh and I would
submit to uh to the legislature that if
to prevent uh any such case as that
which spurns this hearing U from
happening again then it's certainly
within the legislature's purview to say
that every uh that in no case shall a
recording made be uh dispensed with
deleted um less than 60 days or 90 days
that's what I was actually thinking it
seems to me so in this situation the the
driver gets a citation well you your
point is correct he could have called
and made a complaint but the the
instructions he received from the
trooper would have said you can file an
objection to this citation within so
many days with the court so he naturally
did that
and so and when you said you know if he
would have called and said the reason I
was speeding is because there was a
vehicle on my bumper and it happened to
be your trooper that would have indeed I
think been relevant in the hearing so it
seems to me that if you would have held
on to the tape had he committed a
criminal offense because it would have
been evidence of of that crime he should
have access to it so long as he has uh
an Avenue to appeal the citation so if
the citation is a 30-day
window and generally it's probably going
to be another what month after that
before he even gets into into court for
his citation hearing I think it would
depend on the court but they're they're
not particularly quick yeah so I I think
your your suggestion of 60 days um just
a flat 60 days just double the time
period would cover that without having
to get into the minutia of why just
period yes sir uh lastly the point that
I'll make is uh with regard to volume in
terms of efficiency the state police
issued
32,36 summonses in calendar year 2024 3
2000 um yes sir and uh there is of
course a cost with uh lodging videos in
the cloud um we have several terabytes
at this point in time having launched
our program in uh the spring of
2022 uh and obviously that is very
expensive uh many agencies can't uh
can't sustain the cost for that uh the
bodyw war camera project in and of
itself was in response to an order of
the governor and the Lea commission's 48
recommendations we um have used and had
a plan to use Cruiser cameras um the
body warn issue um in a state where
people enjoy their own Liberties
particularly in in uh personal property
is is uh it can be uh tricky in New
Hampshire but that's a lot of data and a
lot of expense particularly for small
agencies to bear and for our agency to
bear as well do you
know what the increase in cost would be
to keep it for an additional 30 days I
do not know okay okay you think you
could inquire and get back to me if yes
sir if it's possible to determine that
yes sir happy to do so I'd appreciate
that thank you very much any further
questions for the
major see none thank you for your
testimony thank you
anyone else wishing to testifying Bill
who hasn't testified see you n i here by
Clos public
hearing reopen at 10: for the next
hearing
e
e e
morning I'm opening a public hearing for
House Bill 638 and I invite the prime
sponsor to introduce his
Bill thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
representative David Muse I represent
the people of Portsmouth Newington and
Newcastle and I come before you today to
introduce house bill
638 while this bill has already received
some attention because at some point it
would impact the parole eligibility of a
person who is at the center of a very
famous case here in New Hampshire if it
passed I want to be very clear that this
legislation is not about a particular
individual or about a particular case
what it is about is weighing the cost
and benefits of unending State
retribution against people who may no
longer pose a threat to society
what HB 638 would do is make it possible
even for people who have received the
harshest sentence of our criminal
justice system to earn a second look
into their incarceration from society
and our criminal justice system and the
possibility of Mercy in their Elder
years in our state the penalty for the
intentional killing of another person
with premeditation or while committing
certain crimes is life in prison without
parole at the end of 2024
there were a total of 95 people in our
state prison system serving life
sentences without parole under the bill
those people would automatically become
eligible for a parole hearing when they
turn age 60 provided they've served at
least 18 years of their sentence and as
long as they haven't committed a major
conduct violation in the past 10 years
according to data the Department of
Corrections provided in the fiscal note
15 inmates would been eligible at the
end of
2024 under the parameters of this bill
but that number could change slightly
over time uh uh Before the bill takes
effect as other inmates become newly
eligible and as as some may pass away to
be very clear this bill is not a get out
of jail free card all it does is make a
very small number of people eligible for
a date with one of the toughest parole
boards in the
Northeast something that surprised me in
the FIS note and I'm sure it surprised
some other folks on the committee too is
that the annual cost of incarcerating a
pris a prison inmate in the general
population is now estimated at
$78,500
and my time on this committee the figure
we've most often seen has been closer to
$35,000 something to keep in mind is
that older inmates often have
significantly higher health care
expenses and that prison can be a very
difficult PR place place to practice
good diet exercise uh and good health
habits but even in prison there are no
walls that can keep out the challenges
that often come with old age like heart
disease deteriorating joints strokes and
dementia older inmates cost more and
present unique challenges to correction
staff while this bill won't eliminate
those challenges it could ease
them this bill would also in no way
impact the Constitutional ability of the
governor to Pardon or commute the
sentences of people in this situation
but what it would do is provide another
Avenue for people to make their case it
would simply provide those who qualify
with the opportunity to present their
case before the parole board and the
parole board would then make a judgment
based on the facts and based on the
person's suitability for
release something I would like to point
out is that under this bill prisoners
convicted of capital murder under RSA
6301 would not be
eligible the elephant in the room for a
bill like this is actually a small woman
who has spent much of the last three
decades in prison in New York state
while pamila smart can't be here today
for obvious reasons she has written a
letter uh to me supporting the need for
the bill which I've shared with members
of the committee you can read her letter
for yourself I want to be very clear
that I am not here to defend Pamela
Smart or to advocate for the release of
a person convicted by a jury of her
peers that's for people with a much
higher pay grade than me what I am here
to do is to advocate for her ability to
get a
hearing prison is not just about
Rehabilitation it is also about
punishment and
retribution what this bill asks us to
decide is whether there is a point where
our need for contribution as a society
can end or if there is always a need to
continue it even when it comes to
elderly people imprisoned for decades
who are only asking for something that
every other inmate in our prison system
is eligible for a hearing before the
toughest parole board in the
Northeast I ask you to give this bill
your consideration and an not to pass
recommendation and I will take your
questions thank you representative
representative does your bill have uh um
a contingency where it
asks the victim or the relatives of the
victims um if they would support the
parole it it does not but I want to
point out that our parole process does
allow for that so victims would would
have the ability to weigh in uh as they
do now in cases that come before the
parole board thank you representative
rhs thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I I will say that you
did answer a couple of them um about the
average time and so forth so thank you
for that um I'm just curious so my
understanding is it's about
$237 a day for an average person that's
incarcerated um do you have a number or
have given any thought to so if the
person Ser is serving a life sentence
they've been incarcerated for at least
18 years is what I think that you had
said um how would that person go about
supporting themselves if they were to be
released as far as housing career
Transportation I I believe that is part
of the parole process um it's not only
whether you qualify uh you know for
parole based on things like your
behavior it's whether or not you
actually have a support network on the
outside so that's something that um
either that's that's something that um
that would have to be in place you know
for somebody to receive Parole in a situ
ation like this may I follow up Mr
chairman um so so just to follow up when
you say something in in place I'm
specifically thinking are are you
thinking for the public to be
responsible or for them to actually find
their get themselves a career and in
their own place to live and so forth
It's a place to go and my understanding
of the parole system is that sometimes
people are paralled and uh they are
paroled into things like halfway houses
and and and things like that where they
can kind of get um uh some type of uh
some type of assistance um before they
before they actually have to go back and
earn a living and like like everybody
else um in a situation like this I would
probably Hazard a guess that these folks
would have helped from people on the
outside any further questions yes
representative pette thank you for
taking my question um I just wanted to
know what the rationale is um you said
like you know elderly prisoners over the
age of 60 and I'm just wondering if
there was any rationale that that led
you to choose 60 as being a number I'm
sorry could you speak into your
microphone a
little thank you I was just wondering
what your rationale is um or was to
choose 60 as as the age over
60 I I think part part of it is um
I don't think we wanted to have a lot of
folks be eligible right away for this so
so I think when you
choose by choosing 60 years as the
minimum age and a and a minimum of 18
years served uh it really Narrows down
the number of people who you know would
be eligible for something like this so
um I think we're always in a position
when we make up laws we sort of have to
make up cut off points and and you know
when things of that nature but um one
thing I can tell you having been age 60
myself and now being older than that uh
is that that's when a lot of you know
healthc care issues really do start to
rear up and one of the things to keep in
mind and and you'll have this
opportunity we'll probably all have it
later in the session is when we take a
tour you know of the state the state
prison is one of the things that will
strike you immediately is this is not a
place where you know you're going to
have lots of access to uh to healthy
eating and exercise and good diet and
it's a very hard place to stay healthy
uh and you're also in a situation where
you're crowded in there with other
people and you know it's it's very easy
to get communicable diseases you know
and things of that nature so you know
the bottom line is is um while some of
us on on the outside might be pretty
hail and party at age 60 um my guess is
the average person in our state prison
system probably isn't quite as healthy
thank you
y see no further questions thank
you okay just so everyone knows we have
looks like an excess of a dozen cards so
we're going to limit testimony to three
minutes please um keep keep that in mind
if you have testimony written turn it in
don't write it don't read it to us and
and try not to repeat what other people
have said with that I call Alexander
Bailey Alexander Bailey
please how how we doing oh there we go
okay uh good morning chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is
Alexander Bailey and thank you so much
for hearing my testimony um I am here um
as a two-time survivor of violent crime
um once as uh an underage sex offense um
that was part of a double homicide that
resulted in a life without the
possibility of parole sentence um and
then as a grown woman unfortunately as a
survivor of domestic violence I'm an
advocate for domestic violence survivors
all across the country and have been
Central to passing laws for criminalized
Survivor who are serving long or
indeterminant sentences I also have the
honor of being the chair of the board of
drop elap New England um which my uh
colleague Dr bashani Reese founded and
asked me to chair because she is a
fellow Survivor of violent crime but I'm
actually here today to testify in favor
of this
legislation um I do believe that there
can be both Redemption and
responsibility taken by people who are
harmed the study that will be quoted
later on which was the first national
study ever done of how victims feel
about Second Chances um including those
who have survived violent crime I was
actually interviewed for um so I'm
actually part of that study and what you
will hear is that a large percentage of
survivors would actually like to see
Rehabilitation and Second Chances um and
restorative justice be the thing that is
enthroned within our system
as opposed to Perpetual punishment but
as somebody who has helped people who
are very senior and elderly leave prison
one of my most recent successes is a
woman in Oklahoma who served 34 years of
incarceration simply for surviving
domestic violence um she didn't even
kill her husband her brother did um and
she was serving a life without the
possibility of parole sentence life
without parole sentences do not allow
the system to go back in review it does
not allow for Relief either fiscal or
moral um and so this type of legislation
gives the courts a very narrow in this
case a very very narrow opportunity to
both provide Redemption but then also to
allow to unburden your
system uh one of the things that our our
sponsor pointed out is that um 60 years
old out here might seem robust um the
studies that have been done on this
would suggest that 55
is elderly in prison for very obvious
reasons you're obviously uh living in a
very difficult environment at times a
violent environment um injury is often
not treated uh adequate medical um
adequate food um a lot of studies show
that people um are actually 15 to 20
years older physically than they are
numerically so what you're going to be
dealing with at 60 years old is what you
might be dealing with at 70 or 80 years
old in terms of
health
think the last thing I would like to say
is that victims are not a monolith I
understand and respect people who have
survived violent crime I'm one of
them but also some of us forgive our
perpetrators and we're often not
heard we're not given that
opportunity so please listen to both
sides today thank you thank you for
sharing your story
chair calls Russell
rocks Roy oh
Roy good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Russell Roy I'm
a private citizen living in
Manchester the chairman and I aren't
related to the best of my knowledge
did your family come from
Canada yes we we are from Canada yes B
tush I I I apologize uh for reading my
testimony this morning I'm a little bit
nervous up here and you don't want me
Meandering
um if you'll en julge me I'm going to
share a brief story with you many years
ago right here in conquer two young men
were friends with a common Bond both
were addicted to pills 20-year-old
Gary's narcotics addition came about as
a result of painkillers he' been
prescribed when at age 16 he was hit by
a car at high speed and seriously
injured 17-year-old james' circumstances
is unknown to me but one night strung
out and drunk the two joined a bunch of
other young people in various stages of
intoxication parting out in back of the
New Hampshire state liquor store among
the partyers was a 19-year-old Michael
stit an acquaintance of theirs who
happened to owe Gary a $20 debt it
wasn't long before Gary was up in his
face about it tempers flared and the
pair began to
Grapple it was then that James threw a
knife on the ground at his friend's feet
impulsively Gary picked up the knife and
stabbed Michael three times killing him
in Cold
Blood the pair ran but it wasn't long
before they were apprehended or arrested
charged and in separate trials convicted
first-degree murder life without the
possibility of parole an extreme
sentence for a horrific
crime that was in
1976 eight years later in 1984 James
Smith the younger of the two
codefendants just 17 at the time of his
conviction committed suicide while
serving out his life
sentence and today in 20 25 at age 69
the older of the two Gary prayer feather
Pharaoh remains in prison having served
49 years almost half a century for his
actions on that fateful
night is currently the longest serving
prisoner in the state of New
Hampshire ladies and gentlemen of the
committee I can say without equivocation
each of us must be accountable for the
decisions we make in life for the
actions we take and especially when one
is the cause of great
harm however there is no amount of years
served or reparations made or sorrow
expressed that can ever fully make up
for the taking of another's
life this much can be said though to as
great an extent practicable and within
the constraints of the rehabilitative
our rehabilitative correction system
Gary pharoh has expressed remorse for
his crime to whomever would listen over
his years behind bars he was has earned
an associates degree in Business
becoming a complished woodworker and
artist remained behaviorally
trouble-free and for over for the past
two decades has been a devout adherent
of the Lakota Sue Faith tradition who
have welcomed them into their
Community I ask
you what purpose Beyond rep retribution
is served by insisting that a
rehabilitated elderly person such as Mr
Pharaoh draw his last breath from behind
Mars providing an opportunity for
individuals such as Mr pharaoh to make
their case of sincere remorse and
accountability before the parole board
and the community at large Who Remain
the final arbitras is all that we ask
and what this bill will
accomplish I humbly ask that you search
your heart and provide some measure of
Hope for elderly prisoners by casting
your vote in favor of this legislation
thank you for your time attention and
consideration and I'll entertain any
questions thank you for your
testimony you're
wel chair call Sarah Mattis
good morning chair Roy Vice chair rhs
and the respective members of the
criminal justice public and Safety
Committee my name is Sarah Mata and I'm
speaking in support of HB
638 I believe it is essential to create
meaningful parole opportunities for
those aged 60 and above who have served
at least 18 years in prison individuals
who can demonstrate growth and
Rehabilitation who pose no threat to
Public Safety but deserve a chance at
release first and foremost I want to
make it clear that my support for this
bill does not diminish the pain
experienced by victims and their
families rather the goal is to promote
forgiveness Redemption and healing for
all
involved many of us assume that harsh
sentences bring relief or closure to the
families affected by the actions of our
loved ones however the reality is is
that harsh sentencing does not provide
True Justice my loved one and I
understand that the actions he made at
age 18 created a ripple effect much like
that of a stone skimming across the
water this Ripple extends not only to
the victims but also to their families
and the families of those
incarcerated the purpose of his bill as
representative M said is not a get out
of jail free card but to provide
individuals who are eligible with the
opportunity to believe in their capacity
to change it gives them a chance to
transform their lives take control of
their thinking and reconcile with their
past actions fully understanding the
far-reaching efforts of those actions
and their
consequences as he and I reflect on the
26 years my loved one has already served
we come to realize that he had two
choices one blame society his youth lack
of Education Etc thus becoming what we
cons would consider a hardened
individual with no regard for society or
his own accountability the other is the
one he chose the length of time he has
and is serving is an opportunity to make
better choices work on changing his
behavior take accountability and
transform his thinking and his
compassion for others this
transformation ensures that he and other
inites like him will never walk down
that same destructive path that led them
to prison in the first place this bill
acknowledges that a young person
entering prison at age 18 is not the
same as someone leaving at age 50 or 60
statistics show that with the support of
family and educational opportunities
recidivism rates and reoffence
percentages are significantly lower in
fact harsh sentences like life without
parole or lwop do not deter crime
instead when inmates are given the
chance to change whether through formal
education learning a trade or personal
growth they can become productive
members of society here in New Hampshire
we live among many former inmates some
are my friends who have spent 25 30 or
even 35 years in prison today these men
and women are
remorseful hardworking individuals who
are giving back to their communities we
don't often hear these stories because
they don't fit that lock them up and
throw away the key mentality but they
are a testament to the power of second
chances for these reasons I urge the
committee to vote favorably on HP 638
thank you for your time and
consideration on this vital legislation
thank you for your testimony
chair calls mallerie
Lee good
morning as an inhome therapist and
manager of treatment in the community as
well as a formal clinical case manager
at the Northern New Hampshire
Correctional Facility I've spent my
career working with individuals who have
endured immense trauma and hardship my
role has allowed me to witness firsthand
the transformative power of
Rehabilitation when individuals are
provided with meaningful opportunities
for go growth self-reflection and
accountability I am speaking in support
of a proposed bill that would Grant
parole eligibility to incarcerated
individuals aged 60 or older who have
served at least 18 years of a life
sentence for first-degree murder
provided that they have maintained good
behavior over an extended period this
legislation acknowledges that
rehabilitation is possible and offers a
pathway for those who have demonstrated
genuine transformation to reintegrate
into
society one such individual who
exemplifies this possibility is Mr Gary
Place although mental health and
rehabilitative programs are ready
readily available in Correctional
settings participation is not a
requirement many individuals declin to
engage in these opportunities but Gary
has demonstrated remarkable self
motivation in utilizing every available
resource to Foster his own growth his
record includes pages of documented
participation in rehabilitative
programming not only as a recipient but
as a facilitator and leader among his
peers he has chosen to engage in
intensive therapeutic interventions
skill building initiatives and wellness
programs that address all domains of
Rehabilitation including mental
emotional social and Vocational Wellness
his re abilitation has not been passive
it has been holistic intentional and
impactful PTSD is an area of particular
concern in my field and throughout my
career I have seen its devastating
effects on IND individuals across the
lifespan from young children to adults
the psychological and phys physiological
impacts of combat trauma are profound
often manifesting in ways that are not
fully understood until decades
later Gary like many veterans returned
from war carrying the weight of
experiences that changed him he was
trained for combat and conditioned to
survive in high stress environments
which deeply affected his mindset in
responses to Danger at the time of his
offense the long-term consequences of
PTSD were not as well understood as they
are today while we still have much to
learn what we do know is that
individuals who engage in consistent
structured therapeutic interventions
like Gary can successfully process
trauma develop coping mechanisms and
Lead meaningful productive lives beyond
his personal transformation Gary now
serves as a leader and Mentor within the
prison system he has helped others take
accountability for their actions develop
self-awareness and create tangible steps
toward personal growth his work has had
a ripple effect inspiring fellow inmates
to engage in the rehabilitative process
which ultimately benefits not only
individuals but the broader Community
furthermore Gary has a robust and
well-structured re-entry plan supported
by a dedicated family unit prepared to
assist in his transition his V vision
for the future is not only centered on
his own success but on helping others
Thrive and grow
this
oh
okay for these reasons I strongly urge
you to support this bill it is not only
a matter of fairness but of recognizing
the true potential of human
transformation when given the right
tools guidance and support thank you
thank thank you and as a reminder if you
do have a written testimony you can pass
it in and we'll review it thank you Ste
Foster share calls Steven Foster
good morning chairman and uh members of
the committee thank you for having me
here today um this is going to be
essentially long for what you just said
you all have a copy I said if you if
you've if you have a copy for us or you
gave everybody C then you don't need to
read it all right I want to just go on
record sure absolutely yeah for uh the
bill 638 I'm uh retired and disabled
100% disabled veteran from the US Army
served in Iraq did a lot of good stuff
over there and uh I know a lot about
leadership I know how to read people I
just spent I just finished up six years
at uh Northern Correctional Facility in
Berlin I was the business professor at
the school and I had other jobs there as
well as um subcommittees and committees
for uh veterans groups that's where I
met Gary place what a wonderful guy this
guy is I mean I know we had a bad day a
long time ago but he's uh he's got many
many years in and U it's you see guys
come in and they get they get 20 25
years and I believe he was
misrepresented uh he just turned himself
in and just spoke openly without
attorney and that's uh that was how he
did that's but that's Gary Gary's a
straightup guy he took responsibility
for the bad things he did and he's been
uh I'll tell you a little story about
Gary real quick then we'll wrap up he um
he's been in there 40 something years
maybe 50 now um and he has one ticket
you know what a ticket is in prison it's
when you do something bad well one day
in the 80s Somewhere In 1980 Something
he got a ticket for putting um some
screening in his window sill to keep the
bugs from coming in that's it no other
tickets just a quiet now he's old and so
we talked about the age 50 60 stuff like
that at 60 in the prison I've I've
witnessed these people they're on their
last leg they're of no danger in general
um I just want to go on record for
saying that that my opinion is that of
of all my life experience they're not
very threatening at age
60 and uh Gary place has a special place
in my heart um like I said I did two
years in Massachusetts Department of
Corrections as a as a CO and six years
as an instructor for business school and
uh I think I uh I I can speak on this
subject and that's what I want to do I
want to say good things for Gary place
it's all in here and I want to thank
everybody for your time I know I'm
limited so U read this it's a good it's
a good right and uh don't read it before
bed no I'm just kidding um thank you for
everything guys thank you thank you for
your service who did you serve with over
in Iraq I was with uh the 101st field
artillery we turned them into an
infantry unit and um I also worked for
Blackwater over there as soon as I got
on the ground they came and got me I was
with the third armor division nice thank
you for your support you're welcome um
thank you thank
you Dr bashani
Reese good morning
this is just my little prop to make sure
that I don't totally go blank um good
morning esteemed members of the
committee my name is Dr bashani Ree and
I am here to testify in support of HB
638 I find myself in an interesting
position here because I wear two hats in
this situation on the one hand I hold a
doctorate in forensic psychology
specializing and studying violence and
risk assessment and dangerousness
assessment for the last decade but on
the other hand I'm a Survivor of
attempted
murder it's the kind of story that can
be quite upsetting actually when I share
it I was attacked
choked dragged by my hair pistol
whipped as I was losing
Consciousness I saw my own body in a
river and the only reason that I
survived was because the as salant let
me
go still just despite all of that I
didn't want a life sentence for this
person I wanted him to be held
accountable and I wanted him to
change and it turns out that as a
Survivor I'm not alone my colleague
referenced uh quite a phenomenal study
that was done in 2022 it's the national
survey of victim's views on crime and
safety and it was found that two out of
three survivors of crime prefer
shorter prison sentences if you combine
that with spending on prevention and
Rehabilitation versus just simply prison
sentences that are as long as humanly
possible also by a margin of 3 to one
survivors prefer having other options to
hold the person accountable Beyond
prison like required treatment
Rehabilitation Mental Health Care
addiction recovery things of that nature
and lastly three out of four survivors
support reducing a prison sentence for a
person who is actively
engaging in Rehabilitation job training
education mentoring peers
Etc these perspectives are in line with
the survivors that I have worked with in
restorative justice where we are looking
for a type of healing that cannot be
found through a lifetime of
incarceration
I ask myself the question what is
Justice and for me personally I land on
something that includes both
accountability and the possibility that
that person can
change so I urge the committee please
seriously consider HB 638 thank you for
your
time thank you for your
testimony oh go ahead representative
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question I believe you had said that
you spent quite a long time studying um
the dangerousness right yes um and I'm
curious about people within this age
group we saying 60 plus um what have you
found if anything what have you found
about what is the level of danger at
that age or past that age thank you for
the question and just just briefly um I
would say every person is individual so
you have to evaluate in an individual
context but we've found it's 40 years
worth of criminological research that
has long established that people age out
of crime and that includes murder um
Peak crime rates are at early 20s that's
sort of when it Peaks by the time a
person is 45 we're talking about a
recidivism rate as low as 2% for any
kind of recidivating you know not even
thinking about violence thank you for
the question appreciate
that repr
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question can you tell me if
bills like this have been uh considered
or introduced in other states oh
absolutely yeah I I'll stick to New
England since we're here in New England
we have a kind of second look bill in
almost every state at this point but the
one I I'd love to tell you about is
Vermont actually has a robust second
look build that would be much broader
than this would include a lot more
people not just life without parole but
people serving extreme sentences and
that bill in Vermont has bipartisan
support um we have a republican sponsor
on the house side thank you thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your
testimony the chair calls Laura
Shuan good morning and um thank you for
listening to me um I am here in support
of Bill
638 and um the reason is that uh I
believe that a person who has been
incarcerated for a long time that has
shown remorse that has um done as much
as possible that they could do to become
a good member of the society that
they're in and to be able to have the
hope of being free
again um I think that if somebody is
incarcerated with life for life without
parole that they're going to be hopeless
and most people won't do anything to
better themselves um if they have the
possibility of getting out again and
that they have to follow certain
guidelines um I think that it's a fair
thing to to have that chance for Freedom
again
um you have heard about Gary place he's
a good friend of mine and my husband's I
met him about 25 years ago and he
impressed me right from the start um he
is one of the few people from what I've
heard that has gone way over and above
uh what somebody in his position
normally would do
so um I guess I'm just mostly just here
in support of the bill for everybody not
just for Gary place of course but for
anybody that would
qualify thank you very much for
Testimony
you chair calls Donald
Ryder good morning ladies and gentlemen
oh
good morning ladies and gentlemen my
name is uh Donald Ryder I am a uh
professional logger in the state of New
Hampshire and you'll be happy to hear
that uh we haven't cut all the trees yet
um New Hampshire is still the most
forested uh state in the uh United
States um I'm here in support of this
bill um I have been in contact with a uh
prisoner in the Berlin jail for 25 years
and uh what I'm learned from here
is that um people can
change um if a
prisoner has committed this terrible
crime um and he had the ability to use
this bill to get freedom I would think
he would have
to really you know tow the line and uh
um be a better person and learn to be a
better person um if he does not have
this ability then um I think you're
going to lose a lot of people through
the cracks and uh they're going to end
up dying in prison um as could be my
friend
um I I really think that um you know the
times are
changing um you know it used to be that
marijuana was a terrible drug and so on
and state after state is now um is
legalizing it uh not New Hampshire uh
but I feel that that is uh coming this
way in the future and um and I know that
there's a lot of states that have
programs for these folks um like my
friend
Gary and he could um excuse
me those those programs could be
implemented in the state the state
also
um I guess that's all I have to say um
other
than if if a prisoner has the guts to do
this and get out of you know and to the
line and get out of prison um this life
we lead is not is not that great as it
all seems uh you know I drove through a
white out snowstorm to get here and uh
and
and and it just it's it's hard to be you
know out here and uh doing what we do
every
day um and uh I'm not saying prison life
is easy but uh you know it's it's it's a
tough decision and uh that's all I got
to say thank you guys very much thank
you for coming all right
the chair calls The Honorable Robert the
Burge
okay thank you uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm going to be
very very brief you have in front of you
my written testimony I've been in the
house for 24 years I know what it's like
I've cheered committees and when you
have a slew of pink cards I can
understand where the chairman would have
some frustration just two things that I
wanted to point out uh in my testimony
now out of respect for the sponsors of
the bill I would like you to um
disregard the criteria that I mentioned
in one of the uh uh the paragraphs that
I have listed only because I didn't want
to disrupt or upset the bill before you
but the second point I want to make is
that I've known um Gary and you're going
to hear other stories so I don't have to
reiterate that but um both Gary and I
are Vietnam War veterans uh I strongly
believe that at the time that he was
sentenced if
PTSD was known and the factors and how
it relate that his sentences would have
been different that's all I have Mr
chairman out of respect for time thank
you and I appreciate that
chair calls Eric
Reed good morning Mr chairman and
committee thank you for having this
meeting for us um I'm the nephew of Gary
place I've been a supporter of his for
42 years now um 42 years ago we lived
one block behind us here on Spring
Street that's where Gary went right
after he committed his crime he
explained to us uh what had happened and
immediately turned himself into the
conquered police station took
accountabil accountability for his
actions
immediately and ever since then of had
respect for him for that plus his
military
service um
Gary requested ex execution but that was
not an option um he was then offered um
a ple bar for 18 years to life and he
refused that because he wanted to be
punished for his
crime uh again taking accountability for
his actions that's basically how we're
raised
um since since then we've uh you know
even as a child as a 10-year-old child
we would visit Gary in prison
consistently to this day I still speak
with him weekly uh for at least an hour
a week uh every Wednesday evening and uh
have meaningful conversations about
helping other people and what we both do
to help other people uh we're a lot
alike in that way um there's a a robust
plan for Gary to continue his work uh if
he was released um we would work
together counseling veterans um and
anyone in need to help avoid
incarceration and
suicide um and basically to give people
hope and that's really where everything
goes wrong when people don't have hope
inside and outside
um one of the questions that came up
earlier is you know what is someone
that's been incarcerated this long due
for support I can tell you Gary's
support system is um as robust as his
his record in prison um he has over 200
pages of support and either
accomplishments or support from others
everywhere from his uh his victim's
sister to his prosecutor that that put
him there in the first place
um so I I think that's pretty remarkable
uh he paved the way with um in his trial
he was the first person in the nation to
be uh to have the PTSD
defense and given the chance he could be
the first one to pave the way for others
U for successful re-entry into the
public
um that's that's about all I have thank
you thank you thank you for sharing the
story
and chair calls Andrew
valinsky good morning chair good morning
members of the committee my name is
Andrew valinski I live in East conquered
uh I come in support of HB
638 um and I come not as a Democrat or
as a former executive counselor but as a
citizen seeking Mercy uh for this group
of individuals uh it's easy to show
Mercy to your friends or to those who
committed minor crimes this would stand
out it would show New Hampshire's
commitment to
Justice HB 638 creates a possibility of
parole this bill would not release
anyone in and of itself the chairman of
the nosh parole board is here he will
speak to you um there is an entire
parole process that evaluates issues
like recidivis recidivism dangerousness
support on the outside questions could
be answered like those asked by the Vice
chair that is part of this process
victims of crimes their relatives
maintain the right to participate in the
parole hearings this bill simply makes a
person eligible to ask for a hearing
you've heard a lot about Gary place I
think of him as the face of this bill he
is my client um he has a remarkable
record at the Berlin facility he's been
locked up since the day of the crime as
his nephew mentioned he turned himself
in and essentially began serving a
sentence at that time he's taken
advantage of every rehab ative uh
opportunity at the prison and has helped
scores of others uh as a former
executive
counselor I want to mention the
commutation process which is what people
would think of takes care of people like
Gary Place who may be deserving of
additional consideration the commutation
process is broken it does not work it's
a political process I was on the ex
executive Council when Gary Place
applied for a commutation in 2018 under
Governor cunu he also applied in
1999 under Governor Shaheen he did not
even get a
hearing in either
case uh councelor Joe Kenny and I voted
for a hearing the other three counselors
denied Mr place even the opportunity to
be heard what this this bill does is it
gives people who qualify under the three
parameters the opportunity to be heard
by a non-political party a non-political
body the parole board who has experience
in AAL valuating the questions that
should be asked about people who've been
in prison who've committed serious
crimes I've submitted written comments
along these lines I've
excerpted uh the extensive extensive
materials submitted to the executive
Council in 2018 and in 1999 they're
appended to my comments I'm happy to
answer questions if anyone has any uh
but I beg your consideration and
recommendation of HB
638 thank you for your testimony thank
you all
chair call Cynthia
musen good morning my name is Cynthia
muso I'm a Staff attorney at the New
England Innocence Project I'm also um a
New Hampshire native I live and work in
hener and I was a criminal defense
attorney for years in the state before I
came here I say this because I can tell
you a couple of things I just wanted to
address a couple of questions um
representative rhs you you asked about
the um possibility for support when the
person is released I just want to
mention that in the normal prison
process you're downgraded and Ste down
through that process but if you have a
life without parole system uh sentence
you don't go through that same process
because there is no downgrading um all
the way to that Community Corrections
level but if you have some parole
eligibility the prison will start
working with you at that point to
develop a parole plan so that you have
support a job and a place to go when
you're released so that's all things
that will be in place and that doesn't
need to be contemplated by the bill
because it is contemplated as everybody
has said by the parole
system um the New England Innocence
Project goal is to um increase fairness
and Justice in the criminal legal system
and uh we fight against wrongful
convictions here um these innocence
cases that we work on teach us how the
criminal legal system fails there have
been 3586 EX Generations in this country
since we started collecting that data in
1989 and over 200 of those were Ser
sentenced to life without parole and
what this tells us is that we're failing
folks not only on the trail level um
with this wrongful conviction but also
compounding that failure by sentencing
them to life without parole and what
we're also being told by this number is
that there are likely innocent people
that have died in prison serving a life
without parole sentence and that they're
innocent folks incarcerated currently
serving life without parole sentences
including in this state these are death
sentences and they are directly
impacting innocent
folks life without parole sentences
don't reduce crime they do not help
Public Safety they disproportionately
impact communities of color and they
cost taxpayers millions of dollars when
we talk about the goals of sentencing
one of them is Preservation of Public
Safety and a lot of folks talk about the
idea of life without parole sentences
really holding up this public safety arm
of sentencing but what we know is that
these prison sentences are not reducing
crime especially for these older folks
we've heard today that the numbers just
don't support this the reality is is
that like the percentage of folks that
are going to recidivate when you get to
overage 55 is pretty significantly low
it's the lowest of any age range um that
exists uh we're not preserving uh any
public safety by keeping these people
incarcerated they're also very expensive
it costs very it's very housely excuse
me it's very costly to house and care
for folks that are incarcerated um it is
uh proven to negatively impact physical
and mental health life expectancy is
reduced for two years for every year of
incarceration that you um undergo um a
significant proportion of the folks that
are on lwop in New Hampshire are over
the age of 55 and so we're spending all
this money on these people that we could
use and reinvest back into our
communities without impacting Public
Safety the proposed bill doesn't as
everybody has already said release folks
out into the community it gives merely a
chance at parole we in New Hampshire
have evidence this idea that we believe
that um just because there's a sentence
it needn't be a death sentence there are
other statutes that contemplate early
release in this state um the only thing
left I have to say is that um the most
important thing as folks have said today
is hope this bill provides that hope and
hope is often all that innocent folks
have uh that holds keeps them holding on
to fight their
freedom thank you very much thank
you the chair calls alilia
Bernette good morning
so I just passed out um some pamphlets
for a re-entry program that I'm
launching good morning chairman and
members of the committee my name is
opilia Bernett healing Justice program
associate with American friend service
committee I advocate for formally and
currently incarcerated individuals and
I'm also launching a re-entry program
for formally incarcerated women coming
home from incarceration and it's it's
also beautiful
re-entry thank you for this opportunity
to testify today in support of HP 638
which would allow individuals aged 60
and older to have served at least 20
years for the first-degree murder to be
eligible for parole this bill is not
about excusing crime it's about
believing in second chances and
improving our justice system as a
society we must acknowledge that people
do change take me for instant some of
you may or may not know that I myself
have been Justice impacted and did four
years in the New Hampshire state prison
for women and I am not the mistake that
I made 20 years ago but I am here now
sitting amongst all of you as a healing
Justice program associate advocating for
formly and incarcerated women so I'm
looking for proof so I'm living proof
here before you that people do change
and Decades of incarceration
particularly for older individuals
changed them in a significant way so the
question is what whether continued
incarceration for this population serve
Justice Public Safety or physical gain
so let's talk about who this is really
impacting I always say that facilities
are called Departments of Corrections
but our behavior is really being
corrected society says incarcerating um
individuals make our community safe but
Studies have shown that it does a
complete opposite let's just touch base
on mental health for a quick second
about 37 % of people in prison have a
history of mental health problems
according to a 2017 report the US
Department of Justice more than 24% have
been previously diagnosed with major
depressive order given the complexity of
the re-entry process a person's health
both in and out of prison likely affects
their ability to avoid crime and follow
parole rules after release many people
leave prison without having their mental
health issues recognized or treated this
often leaves to reoffend commit more
serious crimes and end up back in prison
without support they struggle to find
honest work and push back into Life Of
Crime so let's talk about the the bill
and who this really affects 60-year-old
individuals and older research shows
that elderly individuals pose a
significantly lower risk of recidivism
Rec according to the studies of the US
Department of Justice recidivism rates
drop sharply for those over 60
especially for those who serve long
sentences I mean let's think about it we
all have grandfathers grandmothers for
me my mother is 82 what kind of crime is
she really going to commit at that age
so being in prison can take a
significant toll on individuals and I'm
almost done the Department of
Corrections reported that it costs
78,000 to incarcerate one person per
year These funds can be allocated to
community crime preventions support
services and a program like the one that
I'm starting we should use that money to
build programs and provide the services
and support court that these individuals
need to be successful so let's address
the root causes of incarceration break
down barriers challenges stigmas and
create a more inclusive compassionate
and Sher Society everyone deserves a
second chance to become valued members
of their community so again I urge you
Committee of the I mean I again I urge
you chairman and members of the
committee to support HB 638 thank you
thank you so much for your testimony if
anyone has any questions I'd be more
than welcome to answer them if not thank
you I don't see any thank you thank
you the chair calls grel
Glenn good morning
um my name is grelli I just wanted to I
am speaking in support of this bill um I
wanted to highlight that we already have
in our in our RSA 651 A7 is pretty much
what this the same thing as this bill
except for it excludes first-degree
murder so with this bill it would just
be incorporating and being instead of um
separating of certain people who who've
committed a who we pretty much labeled
them their crime and not giving them the
same opportunity as everyone else gets
um I also wanted to mention a
demographic of of people who are
incarcerated that doesn't usually get
brought up and that's those that are
wrongfully convicted um experts estimate
that there's between six to 15% 15.4% of
people that are wrongfully convicted and
giving that approximately 2.3 million
people are incarcerated that means that
138,000 to 354
,200 of those individuals may be
wrongfully imprisoned at any given time
so this might also be a a hope for those
that have been wrongfully convicted
because let's just face it our justice
system has not always done right by by
people I've experienced it myself
personally um they've made a lot of
mistakes with we're continuing to
correct mistakes by coming up with
different bills and trying to actually
address the um to address Justice and
actually have Justice for for everybody
because where I come from we don't all
get that Justice the same Justice that
you might see for somebody else so um
and I also wanted to highlight from our
Constitution Article 18 where it says
that um all penalties all penalties
ought to be proportionate to the nature
of the offense no wise legislature will
affix the same punishment to the crimes
of death forgery and the like which they
do to to those of murder and treason
where the same IND distinguishing
severity is exerted against all offenses
the people are led to forget the real
distinction in the crimes themselves and
to commit the most flagrant with is a
little compunction as they do those of
the lightest die for the same reason a
multitude of sangary laws is both
impolitic and unjust the true design of
all punishments being to reform not to
exterminate Mankind and people who are
are given the opportunity to come out
spend life in their as exactly that
Exterminating their
existence thank
you thank you for your
testimony the chair calls Sarah
Bonia good morning
um Grand Rising chairman and members of
the committee my name is Sarah Bonia I
am on the leadership team of the oso
beautiful re-entry the women's
initiative I want to say thank you for
allowing me to speak on in support of
Bill HB
638 I want to say that I am formally
incarcerated individual and there was a
time in my life when I made pretty bad
decisions
it took me years after my release to get
my life together due to trauma that
incurred prior and during my
incarceration I was wor worse off upon
my release than I was upon my arrival to
my incarceration and had to seek out my
own help I am now a functioning positive
person in my community and I help many
others with several issues that stem
from incarceration in general but
especially longterm my mistakes did not
define who I am today almost 20 years
later life without parole is a form of
walking death offering no hope for a
future not only do they feel a sense of
hopelessness but their families and
loved ones are punished with the same
sentence watching a loved one grow older
and closer to death with no hope for a
future it takes away a person's right to
Rehabilitation Redemption and
reunification with their families people
do
change I am not who I was 20 years ago
and I believe it is the Justice system's
job to allow for this potential of
rehabil Rehabilitation and Redemption so
I ask you chairman and members of the
committee to please support the bill HB
638 thank
you thank you for your testimony is
there anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill who has not done
so see none I here by close the public
hearing next one
I hereby open the public hearing on
House Bill 670 and I invite the prime
sponsor to introduce their
bill no
in case there are any
questions all right
you ready okay
well good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee um first
time testifying
in this
committee
um HB 670 well let me start uh
representative Len turkot I represent
the towns of barington and straford
which is straford uh County District 4
um the legislation that I've brought
forward was uh brought forward on behalf
of a Rochester citizen who you will get
to hear from shortly Miss Anne Barry
um and will tell her stories uh when I
reached out for other co-sponsors just
reached out for a few and each one of
them actually had individuals within
their own districts that had gone
through a similar
situation um I've also submitted a
testimony of an individual who sent it
into me um I don't think he posted it on
on the website but I put it there for
you and I've also given you a copy the
rsas that actually this refers to just
for your so you know what's going on um
the bill itself what we have done
is
increased the the fines or the if you
will for uh nuisance dog attacks bites
and different things you'll see in the
very first on line 15 of the bill itself
uh they change from 25 to 100 and 100
from 200 I'm not sure when the when
these were last updated but I think $25
I think we could all agree is probably
uh in in need of an updating uh we did
the same for uh line
18 uh bumped those up and the very last
one is really the one that is why we're
here and that was actually vicious
attacks where um as you'll hear Anne
Barry's son uh daughter was viciously
attacked with thousands and thousands of
dollars of damage to her and you'll hear
her story um initially on line 24 I had
bumped that to 2000 until I got word
from ol who said um that's actually a
felony charge which I didn't realize so
that's at at the Thousand the the other
big thing that's added what I think is
Major Improvement is that the owner of
the dog shall be liable for the medical
bills um that wasn't the case prior to
uh this amendment or the bill um as
you'll hear again from an the the the
medical bills sustained were just
astronomical and that should be the
responsible of the dog owner not the
individual who gets
attacked
the
final where is it there it is the last
uh part of it is on page two of the bill
and that's uh line two where we change
the requirement for a municipal court
proceeding after multiple attacks by the
same vicious stocks uh it goes from a
May to a shell um and that's just so it
doesn't give the courts uh the
opportunity to bow out and go well you
know we're not going to handle that we
make that a shell so I mean that's it in
a nutshell I think fairly simple be
happy to answer any questions before you
hear from M Barry
thank you representative um
representative has a question sure thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I apologize I don't have the
text of the bill in front of me I was
just wondering does this only apply to
attacks on humans or does it apply to
attacks in general um if you go to into
in the rsas themselves in the the the uh
piece that I handed out to you it it
kind of addresses that each each of
those different fine increases are for
different types of uh dog nuisances the
big one is actually would be uh RSA 46
46631 uh and G and that's where it says
if whether alone or in a pack with other
dogs it bites attacks Praise on game
animals domestic animals foul or the
important one to me human
beings okay thank you I'll have to look
into
that this thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question representative um
I actually it's it's interesting I I've
had somebody reach out to me about the
same type of situation um and tried to
address it in a slightly different way
but I think approaching the same um
things that would be compatible sure um
but what I wanted to ask in this one and
just for a little background um my door
was broken my side door was broken and
my dog figured out how to get out the
door it's like you know the the
dinosaurs learned how to do the handles
kind of thing well heig figured out how
to do that and uh multiple times
actually once while I was here I got
Tracked Down by you know the um uh house
uh staff here to say your dog is you
know he's he's been found and he's at
the Humane Society so because the fact
that my door was broken he was able to
do this um and I was told by the police
officer when they called um that if it
happened again this is you know maybe
twice or three times in the course of a
month um that I would be charged $25 for
a new fee which you know we we had that
conversation the officer was very kind
and he said of course he didn't want to
have to do that um but you know it was
recurring um and obviously that you know
paying that $25 wasn't going to help me
get my door fixed right so which was the
problem in the first place so my
question to you is do you think I was
wondering if that was your y it's great
I I think it was all pertinent though is
your intention in raising the $25 fee
for nuisance dogs to $100 to punish
someone like me whose door is broken and
who's you know being charged $100 now
instead of 25 is not going to help to
resolve the issue in the first place I I
think that all was necessary yeah I can
that was a lot of comment but I can I I
think there was a question in there um
yeah I what what I would say is yeah um
I think
it each part of that raises the amount I
think to give the owner of the dog a
little bit more incentive to take better
control of their dog I think I don't
know if that's a fair question but yes
if uh if uh your dog continually got out
of a broken door and uh the police said
hey this is the third time he's got out
of your broken door we're going to find
you now $100 versus
25 yeah that's the intent can I follow
up really quickly I it'll actually be
really quickly any point in this did you
fix your
door well yeah working on it okay um and
no okay anyway I'm not going to get into
the Side Story there anyway um point
being uh is there any possibility of
maybe keeping the rest of this and
understanding that of course we don't
want people to be in danger and we we
don't want you know dogs who are
menacing and things like that that that
is a serious issue that I feel like it's
it makes sense to raise the stakes for
that um but but for nuisance
particularly for nuisance is there any
chance of of uh relaxing that part of
your bill as as of a few minutes ago
this bill is officially in your
committee you now have ownership of that
so the any amendments that you would
like to put on that would be up to you
guys okay thank
you thank you thank
you chair calls Anne
Barry good morning first time here so
excited to learn about the ex the uh
experience as well so as um State Rep
tarot indicated my name is Anne Barry
from
Rochester and I am here in support of
the bill as it stands um today for Bill
number
670 so I'm in support of this uh because
I will rewind us to Christmas uh morning
in uh December 25th of
2023 my my uh brother-in-law and sister
were visiting us um from Washington DC
for Christmas day and they brought uh
their leash dog I had my leash dog and
my daughter had her leash dog we were
going for a beautiful and nice Christmas
morning walk before brunch and spending
time with friends and family so feeling
like we were safe in a neighborhood that
we choose to live in in the city of
Rochester and the state of New
Hampshire we were almost complet
completed our walk and out of nowhere a
75 lb
Pitbull what we learned later was a 75lb
pitbull all I saw with my brother-in-law
and daughter walking in front of me with
their dogs and my sister uh and my
myself with our leash dog what we saw
all of the sudden out of the corner of
my eye is our daughter my daughter who
was probably about 5890 pounds being
taken off her feet and to the
ground we didn't know what happened we
didn't know if it was a vehicle a person
an animal it happened so fast that she
was brought to the ground
immediately we started panicking she had
a hold of her leashed dog which is about
a 50 lb
sheepadoodle and we started hearing
screaming not a noise from that pitbull
that was Unleashed coming from one of
the neighbors that we live
near it the attack went on for probably
about 90 seconds to 2 minutes and I ran
to the closest Home to which I believe
then when I realized it was a dog and
ran to a neighbor's home and pounded on
their door for 25 to 30 seconds before
someone would answer the door the owner
of that Unleashed pitbull that was still
attacking my daughter on the ground she
never got up and her
dog that owner was finally able to get
out get out of the home come to the
street side on Christmas morning and
finally get his Pitbull Unleashed bloody
had a piece about this big pulled from
my daughter's sheepadoodle she's on the
ground covered in blood feces her hand
we didn't know if it was a piece of her
pinky missing or if it was hanging off
her blood all over the
place and she's a physician's assistant
so of course we were very worried that
she's got a hand injury immediately my
husband heard he was at home preparing
brunch for us on Christmas morning he
quickly jumped in the car grabbed my
daughter and the dog and I have pictures
that I'm happy to share after um
unfinished he had to drive very fast um
to Portsmouth vet and drop the dog off
missing a piece down to muscle um for
her dog dropped the dog off at
Portsmouth City Vet in Portsmouth New
Hampshire and then immediate essentially
drop the dog in the lobby and bring my
daughter to Portsmith uh emergency room
and my daughter thankfully the dog did
have a rabies shot um and my daughter
had lacerations stitches puncture wounds
PTSD um from that dog attack which was
completely
unnecessary so um her so she recovered I
would say probably within a month's
period of time she just started a new
job so it was a hardship in regards to
her telling a new employer as a
physician's assistant that she would be
out of work um it is in our neighborhood
so you can imagine we're never allowed
to walk her dog in in our neighborhood
and and we do care for that dog quite
often um for her she has other
commitments her dog
spent
total she was fully recovered I will
call it in March of
2024 it was 20 to
$25,000 that it cost her dog ended up
getting some sort of pig um valve
implant to get this wound to heal
because it's a dog
tear um and we
spent it was $9,000 for my daughter's
medical care she's a physician's
assistant so she could care a lot for
herself and knew what was going on so it
was about 25 to
$30,000 for something that as you can
see the fines are very very small today
so that would be one piece of it um
State Rep turkot also talked about the
owner being
liable the owner has not paid paid yet
so we have been out this money um to to
pay for an emergency situation this dog
is a child to my daughter because she
doesn't have children herself so
especially on the portions of the bill
that talk about the owner being liable
we now have to Inc incur additional days
off go to small claims court and try to
force this owner of this dog who admits
the dog was not in
control and we had to incur this on
Christmas day so I'm here today excuse
me on another day that I'm missing from
work my daughter has missed two days um
from work I've missed two days because
we're trying to um just recruit recoup
money from small claims court which
that's a cap at $10,000 so $10,000 when
you're talking 20 to 25 maybe even
upwards of 30,000 we didn't count time
off gas tolls of accommodations we had
to make for them to live with us over
that period of time of of
recovery during the court hearing uh the
gentleman that does own that Unleashed
Pitbull during that court hearing we
just had uh in December or January um
has indicated the dog has done it again
and the dog has been euthanized and we
said that from the start when we called
the police this dog needs to be
euthanized
that is not a normal reaction we all had
leash dogs it wasn't interrogated it
came from behind this person's house
across the street took my daughter again
off her feet and then that dog would
have killed it was seconds away from
killing the dog or my daughter because
she continued to roll on the ground with
a 75 PB
Pitbull so appreciate you letting me
testify today in support of this bill
again I have pictures that I can leave
with whomever as you consider the update
to this bill and I'm happy to answer any
additional
questions thank you if any of the
members want to see the pictures you can
just ask her after I close the hearing
um any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony and sharing your story with us
thank you there anyone else wishing to
testify on this bill wasn't done
so hand to Carden please
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Kurt aronberg I'm the uh
New Hampshire state director of the
Humane Society of the United
States um thank you for the
opportunity uh I don't have a position
either for or against this bill
um the concern I heard from
representative Newell I think is a uh
valid concern there are
many pet owners in New Hampshire
who are lowincome who love their animals
as much as anyone but can't have find it
very hard to afford everything and as
was said
here uh these are family
members um and to uh keep
the
nuisance fine at
$25 sounded to me like a heck of a good
idea
uh not withstanding the other numbers in
the
bill um I would think that would be a
consideration first nuisance offense is
not a big deal as the representative
said it could be a small dog in a uh you
know with a door that's not working of
course you should have fixed it but but
you know that is something
that
$100 for some families really could be a
real problem you know in a week where
they're just trying to make ends meet so
that's you know and there a lot of uh
obstacles to pet ownership for lowincome
people it's expensive but as we said
it's a member of the family and you know
we try to make it as as easy as possible
for people to be in living situations
with their pets so thank you very much
for listening to me thank you for your
testimony you just want to talk to him
you have a
question you can talk if you want go
ahead question I just I feel like I need
to be vindicative at this point would
would you believe that I actually also
had a fire in my house right after this
happened so that is why my door is not
fixed I just want you to understand that
I'm not living in the house of my dog is
down to Massachusetts because can't have
sorry about that so okay all
right feel like that was an appropriate
use of uh do do you
believe
e
e e
open the public hearing on Hospital 700
and invite invite the prime sponsor to
introduce their
bill who's 700 is it me who's 700 who
700 representative love no
than
thank you Mr chair um for the record my
name is representative Kelly Penza
straford District
19 Rochester WS 1 2 3 4 and six I'm here
today
um to make some fixes to something that
I discovered because
um you know I was a recipient of
a of one of these orders I just passed
out to you to you all
um a
copy of what someone fills out for a
stocking
petition the first part of my bill um is
which is really important is to make
sure that when someone goes into the
court and files this especially if
they're doing it um in a retaliation
mode um and not based upon any evidence
and facts that they know that they're
going to be liable to um have a felony
perjury on their record so um that's the
one piece of the bill and the second
piece of the bill goes onto page two of
the handout that I gave you so I'm just
going to give you a the
scenario um an assault happened to a
member of my
family and before that person was
arrested they were in chats and saying
horrible things um they knew my family
member where they went to school they
knew their phone number had their email
address this was a good friend of the
family so the police
advised um us to file this protective
order now this isn't something that we
were familiar with of course so we did
it was after court hours so we did it at
the police
station and we checked off on that page
two boxes number one number two number
four and number 15 and the only reason
why we did this was because the person
hadn't been arrested yet and and we knew
that once they were arrested from
hearing this of course from the police
that they would have bail conditions
meaning no contact with our family and
so we did this in
place unannounced and unknown to
us um once this was filed and then it
went to the other police department for
it to be enacted they went to the
person's home and They confiscated all
of their
weapons that made that
individual extremely angry we didn't
want his weapons taken um all we wanted
to make sure was that there was no
contact at all um that he wasn't
anywhere near our
family
um and how are we supposed to know that
of course you see on here right number
um number six box check is to take
weapons and
so so this all goes down and then within
because it was on a weekend then Within
within um two days cuz he filed in the
court on Monday on Tuesday we have the
Rochester Police come and knock on our
door and um we've got a protective order
once against me and once against my
husband and every box he checked off
saying that you know he fears for the
safety of you know himself and his
family all lies throughout the whole
thing was awful um my daughter mind you
the one that
um took out the protective order was so
freaked out because she thought we were
going to get arrested she fell down the
stairs I mean it was the worst situation
ever um of course we went to court
within 30 days because that's how this
works the person failed to show up it's
immediately dismissed um but then we
still have to go through the process to
get another hearing to go get our
Firearms back all because of a
retaliation I have talked to 10
different police officers in Rochester
I've talked to four different police
officers in Coos County I have talked to
five different police officers in hookit
and this is a common thing so I want I
want this in place I want someone that
is you know a domestic abuse situation
if there is um of course if there is any
sort of stalking situation you know
ex-boyfriend ex-girlfriend whatever it
may be you need to have these in place
of course um and Firearms should be
taken if you're fearing for your life
this that that makes sense and I
understand where due process doesn't
really you know kind of fly in the um in
the sense of taking somebody's Firearms
if there is an imminent threat I
understand all of that but we didn't say
that there was a threat in the sense of
that we feared for you know safety of
that he was going to you know grab a
firearm and do something and
so with this whole thing that happened
um we just realized a gap but every
single one of these police officers said
how common this is so someone takes out
uh you know we don't call it a
restraining order I mean this is a this
is what we were told to fill out um cuz
there isn't there wasn't a perfect
pathway so we thought that this was the
way because you know we checked off box
one 2 4 and 15 um but it didn't matter
once you fill out one of these all of
the weapons are confiscated no matter
what box that you check off and so this
is used all the time in a retaliation
effort and just talking with the police
officers in Rochester that came to our
house not once but twice because they
served my husband first and then me
um they said it's just a gap in the it's
it's a gap and a loophole in the system
and I'm trying to fix that Gap um I'm
happy to answer any questions
um that's where I'm
at thank you um I'm just now looking at
the language does your bill then um make
it so that Firearms are not taken unless
it's requested is that the gist of it
pretty much are you aware of federal law
that says that any protective order
requires all firearms to be
confiscated I am but we don't have
another then there should be another
form that's built then because you've
Incorporated it all into in a sense into
one so there was no other form that we
could have filled out that was no
contact with our family like a
restraining order type of piece um
there's a no trespass but that doesn't
work either because you'd have to put
that no trespass at our home at her
school it it it just didn't work so this
was what we were told to do and but we
were never told that it would go it you
know they they would go relinquish all
his Firearms yeah I I think the problem
is is that it's it's a federal law that
if there's any protective order in place
you can't have firearms so even if we
change this I'm not sure that it will
change the fact that they still can't
have the firearms because of the the
federal law but I'll look at at it and
see if there's a if there's anywhere in
between
that any questions for the
sponsor see you none thank
you rep
love thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the criminal J Justice
committee uh my name is representative
David love I represent Derry Rockingham
13 and uh I've got a a couple uh couple
short stories to tell you what H what's
happened to me uh with similar stuff
here um 20 years ago my ex-wife uh you
know took out a restraining order on me
and you know a weaponized restraining
order uh none of it was true and uh when
we went to court you know 5 days later
uh my my attorney went up to her and her
attorney and said look it we can prove
that you're lying here you know and uh
you know and you have signed a perjury
statement at the bottom here and we will
push for perjury charges so I suggest
you drop it now and she
did okay uh it took me time to get my
guns back and all that but uh about 12
years ago I was uh this friend of mine
or what I thought was a friend of mine
knocked at my door and uh we were having
a hurricane the next you know that
afternoon or whatever and he had a Jeep
with a with a rag top on it you know and
uh he was having a hard time putting it
on he was he was wasn't very well and he
asked me if I'd help him put it on so I
helped him put it on and the hurricane
came and blew the rag top off the top of
his Jeep and then he came to me and said
you owe me
$800 so I did what a lot of people do do
I laughed at him he went to the dairy
Court he filled out a restraining order
and it started out with Mr love wants to
overtake the fed the the United States
government he owns many guns uh things
like this I it was bizarre okay and uh
there was no perjury statement at the
bottom of
that that uh that restraining order and
uh you know I went to court once again
and uh I had brought two people with me
that um you know were were down at the
clerk's office when he was handing in
the papers and he turned around and he
said good I just got his guns taken away
and it's almost hunting
season okay people do weaponize these
things uh you know use them for for
things that they're not intended for but
anyway you know I I won that and uh you
know got my guns back but uh you you
know the fact of the matter is you know
some people need these you know to stay
alive and when when somebody
lies it uh it kind of minimizes what a
restraining order is you know uh you
know uh in in the public perception you
know you know Terry got a restraining
big deal you know his wife's probably
lying anyway is what the people walk on
I I take them take them very serious you
know when when I hear somebody that is
has weaponized a a restraining order I
get pretty mad you know but you know
it's because it's happened to me but
also because it's you know that there
could be people behind me that have
needed uh restraining orders to stay
alive and uh you know this is got to
stop you know and unless we have them
signing perjury statements and the
court we we we have to have civil courts
too um you know to enforce them because
uh they they don't you know is what what
the the problem I've heard you know and
uh you know um I think this is a good
idea it's got a couple little flaws that
uh you know you guys uh it's your bill
now you can amend it to to fix them and
uh you know but let let's let's make
lying a crime when you when you're you
know when when you're going to mess up
somebody's life like that um you know
make a lie a crime you know if if
somebody's opposed to this and and
that's the only thing well don't lie
it's as simple as that thanks thank you
representer anyone oh representative has
a question for you representative share
thank you Mr chair I'm I'm looking at
the uh the stalking uh petition that the
prior witness uh provided us and at the
very end it says I swear the foregoing
is true and correct the best of my
knowledge I understand that making a
false statement on this position will
petition will subject me to criminal
penalties is that statement not on it
what the the one that thank you for you
know give me that question now the one
that uh I had was 10 12 years ago during
that that the last restraining order on
me did not have it are are you aware
that to to charge somebody with perjury
for a sworn statement there doesn't need
to have been a perjury statement as you
describe it on there they can still be
charged with perjury you aware of that
they should be but uh it's it's not
being
done thank
you
representative question thank you for
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question sir um are restraining
orders as they stand now not
automatically
reciprocal I'm not sure
I so if if reciprocity so if I request
for a restraining order on someone
there's automatically in order of
protection it would be back on me where
I can't so it's so there's not okay
thank you yeah there only one one way
MH thank you
chair Co pamel
colleague that
it no more
questions good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee um my name is
Pamela kyg and I'm the public policy
specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence as you know the Coalition is
the umbrella Organization for our 12
Community Based crisis centers who
provide free and confidential services
to nearly 15,000 survivors of sexual and
domestic violence annually and that
includes uh survivors of stocking I'm
joined today by Shauna Foster um the
executive director from one of our
member programs New Beginnings um we are
here in strong opposition to hp700
um which will make it harder for judges
to remove deadly weapons from dangerous
stalkers uh we understand what the
sponsor is trying to address but there
are unintended consequences to this bill
um we shouldn't put the onus on the
victim to check the box in practice it's
automatically done because of a high
rate of lethality in these cases this
isn't a loophole it's very deliberate
and geared at protecting people from
further abuse um so I'm going to turn it
over to shaa and then I'll uh speak a
little bit at the end but thank you so
much for hearing us
today for the record my name is Shauna
Foster and I'm the executive director of
new beginnings without violence and
abuse we are the crisis center located
in Leonia and serving all of belnap
County as someone who has worked
alongside and supported survivors for
over a decade I have significant
concerns about the impact of this bill
and um how it would affect victims of
stalking
in 2024 New Beginnings Advocates
provided 163 services to 50 stalking
victims including 30 Court accompanyment
these accompaniments typically involve
assisting the victim with filing a
stalking order of protection discussing
the judicial process and victim's rights
and accompanying the victim to the final
hearing for their order of
protection last year a new beginnings
Advocate responded to court to help a
victim file for a stocking order of
protection against a neighbor um this
neighbor had been stalking and harassing
the victim the morning that she
presented at court the neighbor had
pulled a gun on her during an
altercation related to the
stalking many victims feel confused and
overwhelmed by the process and this bill
creates additional barriers asking
victims to attest to their truthfulness
not only adds to their shame and
self-blame experience by many stalking
victims but what message does it send to
victims about who should and should not
be believed why are we adding this
language to this particular offense and
not to offend es like
burglary it's also likely to discourage
victims from seeking essential relief
victims should not be afraid of
potential legal consequences when they
are already in fear for their
lives this provision is also unnecessary
stalking petitions already include a
section requiring victims to swear that
the information they provided is true
and accurate and that they could face
penalties if anything submitted is found
to be
false we've attached a copy of a
stalking petition to this
testimony additionally it would Place
victims In Harm's Way by changing the
criteria to remove an offender's
Firearms the relationship between an
offender of stalking and their victim is
not an appropriate measure to determine
whether a case may escalate to lethal
violence judicial discretion is critical
when assessing the level of danger of a
case and the need to remove firearms
from an offender in order to protect the
victim from further
abuse stalking is a serious crime that
can uproot a victim's entire life
Advocate Advocates at New Beginnings and
across the state work tirelessly to
support victims as they navigate the
very scary and dangerous experience of
being stocked survivors go to Great
Lengths to seek help and remove
themselves from the people who cause
them harm whether that be relocating to
another town County or even out of their
state as a result of being stocked
victims often lose their employment
their housing or other areas of support
in their lives they may have to change
their phone numbers email addresses and
social media accounts to prevent the
stalker from engaging with them and even
then stalkers may still find them using
new tactics to continue the abuse bills
like hp700 go against everything we know
as advocates about stalking and the very
real experiences of victims in New
Hampshire we should be doing everything
we can as a state to stop abuse not
creating new Pathways for harm victims
deserve to feel safe and to have peace
of mind they do not need another reason
to keep looking over their shoulders for
the rest of their
lives just in conclusion I think just to
reiterate the incessant and
unpredictable nature of stalking causes
victims to remain in a constant state of
hyper viil vigilance and Terror and this
can also have severe long-term impacts
on their health and well-being all forms
of stalking are dangerous whether the
person is a neighbor an old acquaintance
a dating partner or a stranger stalking
is a serious and potentially lethal
crime and it should be treated as such
uh we ask the committee to please um
consider voting no on
hp700 and ensuring victims that they're
not alone thank you so much
representative Sher I I just need to to
clear up some
language um in my
ignorance we've heard the term stalking
petition and then restraining order and
if not in this hearing we've heard about
protection orders are are those three
different sure um we are using the
language interchangeably for these
purposes there are um domestic violence
orders of protection that require
um an intimate relationship between the
parties um stocking orders of protection
have different criteria for the nature
of the relationship do each of the
petitions that are required whatever
whichever they are and whatever their
names are do they all have this uh
statement where the individual swears to
the truth of what they're saying subject
to criminal penalties yes yes they
do in a order for stalking
it goes the same way as it does for a
protective order and domestic violence
in other words the person
served if the petitioner doesn't check
off the Firearms do the police
confiscate the Firearms
anyway yes so even if I think the Jud
the judge has discretion and so or do
you want to answer that better right so
they they they they go to the police
they fill up the form the police bring
it to the judge if it's a weekend or
they go to cour themselves the judge
then decides whether to check it off he
has discretion and then within how many
days is the usually the follow-up
hearing where the person gets to
actually go in and rebut this um it is
supposed to be scheduled within 30 days
and um the defendant has a right to
expedite the hearing and in that those
cases it will take place within five
business days okay so within five
business days if the defendant goes in
and asks for it to be exit at that point
he or she can petition the judge to have
their firearms returned is that correct
okay thank you further questions yes
representative
M could you let me know who who actually
fills out the form is it the victim or
the police
officer the victim if it's if it's after
hours the police officer is um filling
out the form using the victim's language
and that's submitted to the judge during
court hours the victim is filling out
the petition um
directly followup
follow what kind of you know I'm I'm I'm
thinking about the the testimony of the
sponsor and you know just how hard uh an
experience that is you know for for the
victims as as well
um the whole the whole process
of take take me through how this
actually works a little bit um how do we
actually get to a point where we have a
filled out protective order um and I I
think it's something we all like to
think we understand but it would just be
helpful for me if you could just walk me
through what uh what basically what
happens you know when someone comes to
the police station sure um so in my
experience if this is happening After
Hours the victim is working directly
with the law enforcement officer and if
they have uh met the criteria for a
stocking order the police officer again
fills it out calls the on call Judge and
um they are issuing a telephonic order
of protection that is good until 400
p.m. on the next um court day other
avenues the victims may end up at court
is either presenting on their own if
they know that this is a tool accessible
to them or certainly by calling um New
Beginnings or one of the other 12 um
Member Program crisis centers if they
describe what they're experiencing a
trained Advocate can inform them that
this is a tool that may enhance their
safety and we can accompany them to
court to answer their questions um and
help talk them through the process so
they then fill the document out on their
own um and go to the court clerk and
that's when they're swearing that their
testimony is
truthful you said that the order is good
until 4:00 in the next court day so at
that point the plaintiff has to go in
and actually swear in court to get the
order is that exp party or does the
defendant get the be at that hearing or
not um that part is exp parte okay so
then the defendant gets served a second
time once that new orders and that's
good for up to 30 days is that that's
correct all right thank you see nothing
further thank you for your testimony
thank you very
much chair call Shauna vond Delinda
good morning uh thank you for hearing me
today this is my first time testifying
and uh speaking about my experience
publicly so I appreciate
it my name is Shauna vandelinda and I'm
here to oppose
hp700 eight years ago my family in
particular my parents were the victims
of stalking and harassment from our then
neighbor the events initially started
with targeted insults at accusations
regarding property and then escalated
into a situation where her dogs were let
loose attacking our dog and biting my
father my parents obtained a stalking
order of protection but due to continued
unwarranted harassment and increasingly
fear inducing behavior my parents made
plans to move from the house they had
lived in for 21 years around 3 months
prior to my family moving away from this
person forever she saw them pass by her
house to take our dog for a walk
she then got into her car purposefully
hunted them and ran all of them down
with her
truck then she drove home leaving my
family's bodies in the
street my father Steven was thrown 30
feet and killed instantly for massive
head and chest trauma our dog Lucy
suffered multiple spinal injuries and
had to be
euthanized my mother Aaron was thrown 25
ft suffering multi-stem trauma including
multi-organ injuries and skeletal
fractures including every rib on one
side of her
body after over 30 days in the ICU ICU
neurot trauma units and weeks at a rehab
center she still lives with the physical
repercussions of
that she and the rest of my family
continued to deal with the mental and
emotional aftermath of that life
shattering
event and that's why I'm here today to
oppose this insulting Bill proposed
proposal because it sends the message
that victims of stalking are any less
credible than victims of any other crime
uh what is it about this statute that
requires language reminding petitioners
of the penalty for lying it is this
designed to be an impediment to victims
speaking up for their right to feel and
to be safe because they may not be
believed that is
unacceptable uh this bill presumes that
victims who are being stoed by a
neighbor or a stranger are in any less
danger than those who are being stalked
by an ex- partner or relative when that
is clearly not true my family's trauma
should remind you that we should always
assume that stalkers are in fact
extremely dangerous if a judge has
determined that there are grounds to
issue a protective order they should
always order the relinquishment of a
firearm because our story shows that
when a stalker decides to become violent
they will go to any extreme and even
kill the legislature has a
responsibility to protect citizens in
our state and we cannot afford to weaken
state laws and enable violent
perpetrators to commit lethal crimes so
thank you again for allowing me the
opportunity to speak
today thank you for sharing your story
with us did that happen in New Hampshire
yes thank and CBR okay thank you um no
further questions thank you thank
you the uh chair calls attorney
Enders good afternoon my name is stepen
andw I'm an assistant County attorney in
uh marac County I've been a prosecutor
for over 20 years I do oppose this bill
and as the sponsor said it has two
distinct sections the the first section
is including the language about um false
statements being made on the petition
may be prosecuted for perjury it's
fairly unusual language in the state
normally the
language is that a
uh that false allegations shall be
subject to criminal penalties which goes
beyond perjury includes unsworn
falsification possible false reports of
law enforcement
as attorney Sher pointed out that
language does in fact appear on the
stalking petition as it's now written
and that is um required by law under the
stalking statute it indicates that the
process to be followed and the forms Mir
RSA 173b which is the Civil protective
order 173 B3 paragraph 1 um says any
person filing a petition containing
false allegations of abuse shall be
subject to criminal penalties and
subsection four of that paragraph
indicates that the Circuit Court shall
supply forms and
petitions um all of those forums must
say I
swear that the forgoing information is
true and correct to the best of my
knowledge I understand that making a
false statement on this petition will
subject me to criminal penalties so I
think with reference to the first part
of this bill that language already
exists it's already there with reference
to the the second part which is the um
the taking of firearms under the
stalking statute it is discretionary
within the court of whether or not they
order the relinquishment of
firearms you would asked about federal
law and I think the federal law you're
thinking of is 18 USC
922g and specifically subsection
8 makes it so that a person cannot have
Firearms who's subject to a court order
that was issued after a hearing in which
you had an opportunity to participate
restrains the person from harassing
stalking or threatening an intimate
partner of such person or child so if
there's an intimate partner relationship
it does fall under federal law so
normally when someone goes to get an
order from the court in order of
protection one of the first questions
they ask is who is this against if it's
against an intimate partner they're
encouraged to get an order under 173b
which then has that sort of automatic um
provision under federal law stalking
petitions are more intended for for
stranger situations where people aren't
necessarily in an intimate relationship
and because there is no intimate
relationship it's really up to the
judge's discretion of whether or not to
um order the relinquishment of
firearms it doesn't make sense to me
that the judge would have to or be
restrained from relin ing Firearms
unless the box was checked certainly we
have intelligent judges in this state
that can use their own discretion and
decide when the relinquishment of
firearms is appropriate and I think what
you'll find is in the vast majority of
stalking cases judges are going to order
the relinquishment of firearms because
stalking is a really scary crime and and
as you heard from the person speaking
before me these stalking ERS really are
the first step in what's potentially
intervention a murder so I think most
judges are going to look at this and say
this is a serious thing therefore we're
going to order the relinquishment of
firearms but as it stands right now
judges have complete discretion on
whether or not they do that and I don't
think that discretion should be limited
based on whether or not a box is checked
on the petition I'm certainly happy to
answer any
questions the current state of law in
New Hampshire is either a sworn or
unsworn statement giving false
falsifying it is currently a crime
regardless of whether you say uh I swear
not to or not correct there doesn't need
to be a warning in order for that to be
charged yes no kind of jur necessary um
and have you ever seen a case where
Firearms once the not not at the expart
hearing but at the hearing where the
defendant is present with the council
where Firearms were
returned I not if the stocking order is
issued I'm not well that that's guess I
should have just asked that that second
here when the stocking order was
canceled or overruled right normally if
the stocking order is overruled I think
you have to file a motion for return of
firearms you could certainly do it at
that hearing yeah um I I've never
attended one of those hearings so I'm
not sure how common it is to do it at
the hearing okay thank
you all right thanks thank you anyone
else want you to testify on this bill
hasn't done so
one question
yeah thank you Mr
chair I know that that statement was
there basically I was just hoping that
it could be you know I understand that
making a false statement on this
petition will subject me to criminal
penalties I mean wouldn't it be nice to
have it say under you know you know
pursuant to RSA 6411 or what what the
laws are there I just I just feel as if
it should be
um it it should be more prevalent
and because the retaliation piece was
huge I mean the whole statement was you
know okay um these pages of pages where
you can you know you can write um
whatever you want and and they were all
you know it was all lies and so and of
course it was an immediate retaliation I
am understand I don't want to get
involved at all in any of the domestic
violence peace and I understand that but
I but they have their own petitions and
that's why I picked it on this one
because we were told to fill this out
and also the other question about the
police
department um my daughter was there at
the police department and because it was
after hours she filled it out and then
the police filled out something but we
were there and it was filled out in
person and that was an emergency order
and it went exactly like you you said
until Monday at 400 p.m. um and then
when we went to court he the person had
already been arrested and had bailed
conditions so we immediately dropped the
protective order but there was no
um her
statement that night in the police
department said I just want to make sure
you know because of the stuff that
happening I had my interview with the
child advocate and I want to make sure
that he has no he can't contact me that
was what she wrote and so we had no idea
that the Firearms would be taken the
Firearms being taken is what made this
person go ballistic gotcha so thank
you there be no one else I here I close
the public
hearing we will be in recess till
1:00
e
e e
good afternoon everybody hope you all
enjoyed your lunch it is 1:00 we are
going to open the public hearing for
house spill is it 777 777 for house
spill
777 and we introduce the prime sponsor
introduces legislation
thank you madam chairman um for the
record representative Terry Roy
Rockingham 32 I'm introducing this bill
um actually on behalf of the uh behalf
of the actual the commission itself the
New Hampshire law enforcement
accreditation commission was established
by Governor shunu um by executive order
uh two years ago and we just got it up
and running and we we've accredited our
first um group of group of police
departments after having gone through a
long process of establishing what was
required to achieve
accreditation um and it's rolling along
great but what we want to do now is we
want to put it into statute instead of
just have it on the executive order and
um really that's it we're just trying to
formalize and finalize it um director
Skipper who's also on the commission
with me is here to answer some questions
but I'll take any if you have any right
now representative sheer I can't pass on
this opportunity I didn't think you
would
um how how have you set up how the state
accreditation excuse me intersects with
a Kalia uh accreditation um thank you
that we really don't intersect except
for we um I believe we accept Kalia
accreditation towards New Hampshire
accreditation but it doesn't necessarily
take the place of it um you still have
to meet the minimum New Hampshire
standards if they are higher than Kalia
and director skippo knows more about
that than 9 but I think that's the way
it is thank
you anybody any more questions seeing
none thank you very
much
Skipper thank
you thank you madam chair for the record
John
director of New Hampshire police
standards and
training I uh I am here today to speak
in favor of uh this legislation to
codify the New Hampshire law enforcement
accreditation commission uh as uh
representative Roy spoke to uh this has
been uh an initiative with uh New
Hampshire law enforcement over the last
two years uh the uh commission has
worked very very diligently in
establishing uh accreditation standards
uh working uh with regard to uh
providing training for assessment and
program managers for accreditation and
uh in fact uh we have had uh a number of
uh Mock and actual uh assessments for uh
agencies to become accredited uh the
first agency uh was last week uh that is
the dairy Police Department just uh
received their
accreditation uh and we felt that it was
important to uh codify uh this
commission uh that was initially
established by executive order of uh
Governor sonunu I stand ready to answer
any
questions director uh excuse me um
representative share same question I
posst to representative Roy thank you uh
representative Sher uh in fact uh the
commission is working diligently to
establish what we would refer to as a
bridging document uh that bridging
document will take uh the uh Kalia
standards which is a nationally
recognized uh accreditation program that
uh New Hampshire agencies have access to
uh and in fact we have a number of
agencies to include the Portsmouth
Police Department that is a nationally
accredited agency uh but we want to make
sure that uh we can work kind of hand in
glove uh to establish a bridging
document so that those that have gone
through the uh national accreditation
can easily uh uh reach and attain uh
state level accreditation and then vice
versa you know one one of the other
initiatives is to make sure that
particularly for smaller agencies that
may not have uh that type those types of
resources let's get them State
accredited with the with the hope that
that would uh provide them enough
impetus to move to a national
accreditation thank you I know
Portsmouth having been through the Kia
process it's it's a long expensive and
valuable process but long and
expensive any further
questions seeing none thank you director
skip thank you Mr chair thank you coun
anyone also wishing to testify this bill
who has not done
so seeing none I he right call this
public
hearing H I do yeah
um I hereby open the executive session
on House Bill 77
777 and I make a motion of ought to pass
second um quick discussion as I said
this was um formed by Governor shunu so
that New Hampshire would have our own
accreditation um standards for for our
police
departments and there is a national we
heard about um Kalia which nationally um
sets standards for police departments
around the country um and it is a very
in-depth process um where they come out
and they look at all the things Police
Department are supposed to have um to
keep them professionally um
accredited we felt and director excuse
me Governor SN felt that New Hampshire
was unique in and of itself with our
different laws so that it would benefit
us as a local state to be able to have
local accreditation as well so he
established this and as you heard the
director talk we're trying to merge them
so that people don't have to um depart
departments don't have to have that big
expense but New Hampshire does have its
own set of laws so it's important that
we have a few different um standards
that we add as well so this is a really
good thing to keep um our police
departments at the highest standards
possible um the highest level of
professionalism um so I would ask that
everyone support
it you would like to speak your
second well said Mr chairman thank you
any further discussion or questions
chairman Roy thank you for your question
um I I noticed that there is no fiscal
note whatsoever on this this does not
appear to cost anything to do yeah the
um it it's fund I believe there were
some initial funding from the general
fund when the governor set it up but now
it runs off of um grants from the
federal government and the monies that
the Departments actually
pay
yep seeing no further I'll ask the clerk
to call the role the motion on the floor
is ought to pass
Vice chair roads yes representative PR
yes representative
DeSimone representative
devoid yes representative bogert yes
representative pette yes representative
Sabor dwan yes representative Matson yes
representative Harriet gaite
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes represent resentative
Newell yes representative Sher yes
chairman Roy chair votes yes 160 160
passes unanimously and objection to
consent seeing none it will go on
consent what else we
got
e
e e
I didn't recognize you you look too
formal hey when your bill it's
e
e e
you need the bill no did you open
welcome back everybody I'm going to open
the public hearing for House Bill 778
and we'll invite the prime sponsor to
tell us about his legislation thank you
uh representative Oran Rockingham 32
this is um a bill that would allow the
police officers that work at our um Law
Enforcement Training Center to be able
to work details currently it's a
sacrifice for them to work there to
train police officers because they can't
legally work details so they can't make
the same money as a regular police
officer and we would like to encourage
our best to go and train our newest um
so to ask them to do so at a pay cut I
don't think is fair so that's what this
bill would allow them to do um and I
understand we may have to make a quick
amendment to it that would um make sure
that they can can only do details if
they're requested by a police department
because there may or may not be some
inter agency jealousy worried about
somebody taking details from somebody
else so um but other than that that's
the gist of the bill
questions representative Pro why can't
they take details because it they're not
statutorily allowed to um I guess the
way the statute written somewhere um no
because they don't they don't work for I
don't believe they work for a town they
work for the state so if they're sworn
law enforcement officers in other words
let's say I leave whatever department
and take a job for the state at the
training center I'm still a law enforce
officer but I can't work details because
I I don't work for a department sounds
dumb to me and if I'm wrong he's going
to correct me and that's
fine
yeah representative D
Simone thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question I'm a little
perplexed about that
because if I'm the chief of police in
town a and none of my offices are
available for a detail I can call a
police officer from town BCD whatever I
can't currently call from the state no
not I can call from the sheriff's
department but I can't call from the
state that's correct you can't call them
thank you but if we pass this you can
thank you anything else anybody
else see none thank you very
much just director
skippa welcome
back thank you madam chair uh once again
thank you for your time uh members uh
for the record my name is John skip I'm
the director of New Hampshire police
standards and training uh I here today
to testify in favor of this bill and um
uh would maybe uh just like to add a
little bit to what representative Roy uh
brought uh to your
attention uh we really see this as kind
of a
two-pronged uh effort uh in the first
instance and and rightly so uh as
outlined by representative Roy uh I am
literally drawing Talent from the same
pool of police officers that every other
police agency in the state of New
Hampshire is also pulling from and so uh
from a recruitment and retention
position as the the manager of a
executive branch agency that employs
police officers I have to make sure that
I can provide an opportunity for uh my
police employees to not lose out on a
benefit that they would have while
working at one of the local or state
agencies uh everybody who works for me
presently uh as a police officer as a
trainer and uh they uh in essence gave
up their their opportunity to work
details uh by coming to work at police
standards and training and that's only
because there's no uh legal mechanism
for me to
invoice uh another local agency it's
just not in our law right now and that's
really you know uh the impetus for
moving this forward is so that we can
just establish within RSA
106l uh the authority of the council to
set a detail rate and for me to actually
be able to invoice towns it's it's
almost kind of a
technicality um secondly and to
representative D Simone's uh uh question
and point uh we routinely get calls from
local agencies uh that are attempting to
fill uh details or to get help I can
tell you that during the summer I would
routinely get phone calls from uh Chief
Alex Reno from the Hampton police Police
Department hey we're expecting about
100,000 people here for fireworks and I
can I don't have enough police officers
can you send me some help uh my people
are ready to do it but I had no way to
be able to bill the Hampton Police
Department for those
Services uh we get called routinely from
uh the Lowden Police Department when
they have the races again uh they need
uh security details they need traffic
details uh we are uh experienc in as you
all know a uh a real problem with
Recruitment and Retention of police
officers across the state and so a lot
of these agencies just don't have the
resources to be able to handle these
types of large events uh without uh
getting help from other agencies and and
so really you know uh thank you
representative Roy for uh sponsoring
this but this if it passes would allow
give us the mechanism to be able to to
uh Bill invoice uh those people that are
requesting these
Services uh I would ask that in line
three and I'm no Wordsmith so I would
certainly defer to all of you here uh
and this was at the request of the New
Hampshire uh Chiefs of Police
Association uh to insert the following
language after the word may uh I would
suggest uh at the request of the state
County or local law enforcement agency
of
jurisdiction uh and that is really just
to make sure that obviously the local
police Chiefs the county sheriffs and
and uh those state law enforcement
agencies we would only be
responding to their request we would not
unilaterally uh just detail officers to
something we would wait for a request
for help from whoever was in charge of
that jurisdiction and then we would
provide the services as as we could
I uh I thank you and I stand ready for
any
questions repr R thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my questions skippa
Could you um could you tell me are Are
the officers that are doing this
training there are they still like
accredited police
officers uh uh thank you for the
question in fact uh myself and all of
the other trainers are uh full-time
certified police officers and
statutorily we have uh law enforcement
Authority throughout the state
uh we really just don't have a mechanism
to Bill uh to invoice those other uh
agencies and that's really what this
legislation would help uh help
address represent yes thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh if these officers are
allowed to do a detail uh what vehicle
would they be using if they're using one
that requires a vehicle uh thank you for
that question sir uh we do have a fleet
of vehicles uh
predominantly uh from my position I
don't know that I would detail the
officer with a vehicle per se it would
probably that I would just have them
Drive their own vehicle to the location
I'll give you an example at Hampton
Hampton Beach during the fireworks uh
they'll want officers on a walking beat
really at every block along uh route A1A
and um so the those officers would just
drive their their own car to the Hampton
police department and then they would
get detailed out to their post um there
may be times uh where uh there might be
a request for a vehicle to be part of
that detail and uh just my experience as
a as a uh local police chief I
understand that we would need to build
in a a rate of uh compensation to cover
the cost of that use of that vehicle and
we would would discuss that and
ultimately let the council decide on
what that number would be thank you
sir
Newman if this law passes uh and you
have to set up those kind of details do
you have to make any other statutory
changes or can that all be accomplished
just with this bill well thank you for
that question sir uh it is my
understanding after doing uh a lot of
research that this is really the only uh
change in legislation uh that would be
needed for us to to move forward and and
uh provide that assistance at at request
thank
you seeing nothing else thank you thank
you anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill it was not done so see no not
here but I closes public hearing do
everybody think you want to exec this
for him he's been sitting here for
hours no oh it does it needs an
amendment doesn't it yeah okay we were
going to execute for you but no next
week
Could you
um could you just not right now but when
you get back to the station can you
email me that language just to make sure
we got it right I what I have is um May
at the request of state county or local
law enforcement agency of
jurisdiction
e
e e
I hereby open the executive excuse me
the public hearing on House Bill 7 67
invite the sponsor to introduce this
bill good afternoon Mr chairman and me
members of the criminal justice
committee uh for the record my name is
representative Dave love from I
represent Derry which is Rockingham 13
uh of uh
I I put this bill together uh mainly
that that doesn't take a genius to
figure out it's got a lot to do with uh
with how many Montgomery and other
children have died um you know while
while being um you know having having
open cases or even closed cases uh with
DCF um DCF has a has a lot of good um
social workers and that's what they
trained in in social work and uh
somewhere along the line we uh we gave
them the uh the the uh responsibility of
investigating crimes you know we've got
uh you know we've got children that are
being punched in the face um you know
children that being sexually molested uh
and DCF is investigating they don't have
any investigative experience or training
they uh you know they can't they can't
get a get a warrant uh you know a lot of
times uh if if people have been down
that road with dcy DCF enough uh they
get laughed at or intimidated I imagine
Adam Montgomery probably intimidated a
few workers he was a a big Burly nasty
guy and uh if you if you send a 23 year-
old recent college student uh to to his
house uh I imagine he's going to
threaten and you know I know where you
live and that type of stuff um but uh if
it was a police officer that knocked on
the door it'd be a whole lot different
you know and uh to me it doesn't take a
take doesn't take a crystal ball to
figure out that some kids would be alive
today if police were investigating
crimes um I you know I was on that uh
the committee to uh investigate DCF and
uh you know now senator Pat long and I
were talking and I said Pat if if I jump
over this desk and I come over there and
I punch you in the face somebody calls
the police they come in they question
everybody in the room they haul me off
in handcuffs I have to post bond a bail
then I'm take I have to go to court and
and pay the consequences but if you're
my 5-year-old Son DC dcyf comes out and
somehow it gets kicked under the carpet
you know
uh kids deserve deserve the same the
same rights we have as far as uh being
protected by law can you can you explain
to us what the bill would do the bill
would
um let's it would uh anytime there's a
call a call coming into DCF uh about uh
you know a physical abuse or or sexual
abuse DCF the the next move is to call
law enforcement they do not go
investigate it themselves um you know
let's have some professional
investigators do the job of
investigation and somehow along the line
that isn't always happening here in New
Hampshire and kids are
dying thank you questions for the
sponsor representative Sher uh do you
have any evidence of DC not calling uh
uh police uh when they become aware of a
crime being
committed with how many Montgomery uh
the um it's been well published that the
uh the um investigator emailed
Manchester police after he had been out
there to to investigate and I said
there's no no broken bones there's no
cuts and bruises on the kids I think
we're we're okay okay uh that's that's
not okay to me uh you know when you
you've had 17 complaints of of brutal
violence against somebody uh you know
with with their kids um you know if if a
police officer somebody with with
investigative training had had
investigated this we might have had a a
whole different
outcome do you know if um if a if a
worker from DC
DCF interacts with a a family like that
they're they they come back more often
they're their worker right is that
correct yes I did not imagine so yeah
would it would it make sense that they
would have a relationship with that
family that they were maybe you said
intimidated maybe didn't want to sour or
didn't so they might not necessarily
call the police right away and and that
from what I understand is what happened
with Harmony Montgomery the investigator
new Adam Montgomery from the yd YDC
Center and uh he he had been in there
when he was a 15-year-old and he didn't
want to you know didn't want to Rattle
him so if they were mandated reporters
that would kind of take the pressure off
the DCF worker I had to exactly thank
you further questions yes representative
Murray thank you Mr Taran thank you for
taking my question um I was just kind of
confused with your response to
representative Shear because did you say
that they did report to law enforcement
but then what they reported was that
there was no issue so I if I if I heard
that correctly then how does that bill
change what happened it's my
understanding thanks for the question by
the way um it's my understanding it was
the 17th
complaint okay and um after 17
complaints you you have his buddy come
out and say no there's no problem there
um you know boy did we the state of New
Hampshire dropped the ball no but
clarify please um they reported via
email and via email y um and this this
this bill would make them report
immediately you get the call you make
another call um
okay question they were how do you know
how long after they reported was the
email immediate or was or do you know I
don't know but it was 17 it was on the
17th okay complaint
followup thank you just to clarify so I
guess what I'm saying is if they
reported that there was no problem and
now we're saying that they need to
report you know immediately and then
written
then if they're saying there's no no
problem even if they had called
immediately or sent an EMA or sent a
written report later would they still
have not said that there was no problem
in the report so I guess by changing the
timing of the report how does that
affect what's in the report do you know
what I mean not exactly okay do you know
what I mean I'll translate that one he
reported in the email there's no problem
here how does your bill make it so that
he'd report anything different even
though he's got a call faster
when when the uh DCF call line got the
call and you know these children are
being punched I see that that's where
DCF leaves the leaves the story and the
Manchester police take over so as soon
as they become aware of a potential
crime they call they don't go out there
first and investigate then call exactly
got it thank
you representa
m I just have a just have a hope you can
help me with a clarifying question so
I'm I'm looking at the current statute
and the current statute says the
department shall immediately by
telephone or in person refer all cases
which there is reason to believe any
person under the age of 18 has been
sexually molested sexually exploited
intentionally physically injured so as
to cause bodily injury physically
injured by other than accidental means
so as to cause serious B bodily injury
or victim of of a crime to the local law
enforcement agency in the community in
which the acts of abuse have believed to
have occurred it look to me it looks
like our current statute requires dcyf
to immediately report these cases to law
enforcement anyway so I'm not quite sure
what what your what your bill is trying
to achieve that's any different than
what's being than what's currently in
statute what OS said to me um is and a
lot of what you read is new language um
you know on line two it starts at it IM
immediately refer is crossed out okay
verbally report is the new standard okay
to any any duty officer local law
enforcement agency in the community okay
which which the acts of abuse are
believed to be to have occurred that
according to the bill is all new
language I'm just trying to figure out
if there's anything different I mean
what would a police officer do
differently with the bill than without
the bill no but I'm trying to
determine are you saying that when you
had the bill drafted that was not the
state of the law what he just read to
you that's what uh OLS told
me okay so you checked it yeah no you
checked it all us what's the state of
the law they said hey you said then
write this bill and now we're saying
that that's and you know they've got all
the part of what you said is in changes
here yeah this uh I'm just looking at
what's posted on our online and our
current
statutes okay well maybe your law passed
and we didn't even have to have hearing
go
ahead my my question would be it seems
to me that what the report would have
been had they immediately reported
verbally to the duty officer that there
was nothing wrong there and I don't know
if all of the things that you changed
down here would have changed the report
represent we just asked that question
and was
answered we just asked that
representative Murray and I just went
through that whole whole
silic and the answer was at the phone
call the initial report was she was
punched that's when they would have
called the police and said she was
punched not after they out there
punched she was oh so punched well is
that in here yeah so that that's what
would be different but we still doesn't
get rid of what which one of these now
includes punched as a oh my god did you
see anything no okay all right thank you
representative La we're going to look
into that and see what the current
statute if the current statute is
correct what representative Muse just
wrote it would seem that your your
condition or your um issues been
resolved so we'll check into that thank
you um who
else they probably help us out the chair
calls Susan larby and Maria Nunan
hopefully with answers to those
questions representative Sher uh that's
what representative Muse readed is the
current
statute good afternoon Mr chairman good
afternoon my name is Susan laraby and I
am general counsel and legislative
liaison for
DCF good afternoon my name is Mar Nunan
I'm the uh DCF director thank you we did
submit written uh testimony through the
portal y um however I do have some
copies if you find that would be helpful
um if you want to hand them out
sure' be helpful if you could tell us
what the law says
sure and maybe just to kind of begin as
to why we did do written testimony
because when you look at the reporting
statutes and there's multiple statutes
especially in regards to the response to
child abuse and neglect there are State
statutes as well as the statute here
that is uh presented as a bill today for
an amendment for amending that current
bill I that current statute sorry as
well as federal law and state policies
procedures and protocols in regards to
the multidisciplinar approach to the
investigation the assessment and the
response to alleged child abuse and
neglect so I think we need to look at it
as a whole in order to answer your
questions and provide information for
you
all as you all know throughout the last
couple of decades we've really honed in
on the most important thing in our
country in our state in our in our lives
right the the safety of children the
safety of children from abuse and
neglect and from crimes against them
it started with the mandatory reporting
Statute in which
all adults in our state are mandatory
reporters when they have a suspicion of
abuse and neglect and that mandatory
reporting
statute is outlined in 169
c29 for again all adults in New
Hampshire are mandatory reporters and
then in return in 169 c38
we DCF the Department of Health and
Human Services we are mandatory
reporters to law enforcement when there
is a suspicion that a child has been a
victim of abuse and a victim of any
crime whatsoever so you are right that
has not that is not being changed with
the with this bill what is confusing
about this bill is when it is to be
referred
so what also has enhanced our response
to Childhood abuse and neglect is other
statutes for instance 169
c34 outlines our duties and
responsibilities and our time frames
around the commencement of
Investigations of abuse and neglect and
that is what's called the duties of the
Department of Health and Human Services
and as you see it outlines the most
important part of this Statute in my
opinion is that if a CH if it Fe that
the immediate safety or well-being of a
child is endangered the family may flee
or the child disappear or the facts
otherwise so warrant the department
shall commence an investigation
immediately and that's our duty to begin
that investigation immediately and also
under the reporting statute it's our
responsibility to notify law enforcement
when there is a belief that a child has
been a victim of a crime that happens at
the district level of the jurisdiction
of the district office they refer to law
enforcement the local law enforcement
with a phone call and they follow that
up with what's called a law enforcement
notification
letter laying out what is alleged to
have occurred and beginning that joint
investigation process because what we
have learned over decades is that that
is the best for all of these cases to be
treated as a multidisiplinary team
approach to to the response to child
abuse and
neglect and stakeholders which include
law enforcement DCF the child advocacy
centers uh
prosecutors um therapists came before
the legislature in 169c
34A to bring forward that legislation
years ago when we are finally coming up
to par with other states and putting
child ad vacy centers in every single
County in our state to work together
collaboratively to investigate these
cases and what's also mandated in that
statute is that we put together these
protocols the protocols for the best
practices for following the law both
state and federal and for working
together as a joint partnership to
investigate these cases and that is the
protocols and I provide a a link for you
all because they're they're it's out of
the Department of Justice the Attorney
General's office it's made up of a task
force as required by the statute that
says there is to be a multidisiplinary
task force to study and Advance these
protocols and these Protocols are to be
given to the legislature these Protocols
are to be uh on the public facing
website for each discipline to then be
trained in these protocols for again
best practices of investigating and
responding to abuse and neglect and I
don't have enough for everybody because
it's quite I don't want to kill too many
trees but I do have enough that we could
pass them
around and you will see the chapters are
laid out in the table of contents when
it talks to all the disciplines involved
in the uh response to child abuse and
neglect and I will specifically point
to uh the
appendix which is the last few pages and
this is appendix D when it comes to the
Joint guidelines for DCF and law
enforcement on mandatory notification
record sharing and
investigations specifically Roman
numeral one that talks about the flow
between the mandatory reporting to DCF
to law enforcement with that phone call
and then with that law enforcement
notification letter and if you want to I
can st stop talking for a few minutes if
that would help but I think that would
lay out and answer many of the questions
uh about the reporting that happens um
in a very formal
way um if I could just quickly the
uh what section does the bill p purport
to
change is it one 69 C
29 31 381 yes
correct department shall immediately
okay that's
right so how is the current language in
the statute different from what he's
asking for in the bill
so we're assuming that when it it struck
the word refer that it says the
department shall immediately by
telephone and then there's some
additional language of how that
telephone call is to occur that is to
occur to a actual law enforcement
officer um and then it says that if no
law enforcement officer is available to
then call uh State Police which I'm
again I'm not law enforcement and I'm no
no longer a prosecutor I'm I'm a dcy
general counsel so I can't answer that
question but typically we would as you
see in the flowchart we are calling the
local law enforcement because they have
jurisdiction over the case and state
police would not have
jurisdiction so it would change that and
then it would assume that if they're
talking about striking the word referral
that's what happens when it gets sent to
the local do as we call it the local
district office that has jurisdiction
over that family over that
knows that may know that family may know
the law enforcement that's when the
joint investigation Begins the way we're
reading it is that that would it would
be required that it's actually the
central intake worker who would be
making that phone call to State Police
how long does it take before it gets
sorted through to your district office
and the decision is made to call law
enforcement typically um it's a matter
of hours um before a screening decision
is made but certainly our Central intake
or our hotline staff um are trained in
any immediate danger would be
immediately notified so if A call came
in that said uh the across the street I
just saw the the man punching his
daughter in the face someone needs to
look into this does your intake officer
call the police right then or do they
refer it to the district yes and they
would also probably advise the caller to
call 911 you have that somewhere in your
in your policy or procedure that the
that the intake is supposed to call
right away if they see a um or hear a a
more urgent nature to the call so I'm
not sure if that's in policy our general
Council will look um but our our Central
intake or our hotline staff um are
equipped to make decisions around
timeliness of um response to a um
particular report based on the
information that they reive so there are
screening decisions and and we we have
reports called level one two and three
so in our level one reports those are
our most serious reports a CH is in
danger now so again 911 may need to be
called but also a screening decision
would be made immediately as soon as we
have enough information to make that
decision the local office would be
notified by phone this happens very
quickly and then the local um supervisor
would be connecting with the local
police department to make that immediate
notification
okay is there anything further you
wanted to present Council and just to
clarify again we're not opposed to this
bill we're not in support of this bill
we're here to offer information but
we're also here to offer information and
make sure that there's not unintended
results happening here because as uh
director Nunan stated when there are
those what we call level ones those
immediate concerns for the immediate
danger based on the other statute that
says that ferally and Statewide we have
to abide by that we want to of course
reach out to law enforcement
immediately that's the best practices
and but there are multiple levels of
what we call level ones which are those
let's go everyone needs to be on ready
to dispatch and we always have an on
call supervisor for that and last year
in the state fiscal year
2024 there were
1,173 what we call level ones that
resulted in a notification to law
enforcement a level one that rise to it
may be a crime against a child however
there were also over
2,173 level twos and I did uh provide
policy and procedure that discusses what
each one means and how they're defined
in our uh work as well as a level three
2,254 so of the
5,700 reports to law enforcement the way
we read the bill that would be immediate
dispatch to police and if there's no
local police um available that we would
be calling State Police that would be
over 5,000 5,700 calls that would
immediately flood State Police and we're
concerned that that would have
unintended results I think State Police
um is if you were to call the local
police in some towns don't have police
or some towns only have police between
certain hours of day or night so in
other words if you can't reach them you
call the State Police so I don't think
that means FL State Poli cor correct um
so you're saying that under the way the
way that bill is
written all of your calls would go right
to the police is that what you were just
saying you said 5 that's the way that's
the way we've interpreted it and we made
that assumption when we were doing the
fiscal note worksheet and that's why
it's quite quite a high fiscal note
impact because that would require
especially during after hours in which
during after hours and on the weekends
which is defined as now being included
as that written report whether it be a
level two and a level three level one
that would immediately go out anyways
but the level two or level three would
now have to go out and be dispatch to
our local dcyf as well and our on call
provider is a is a contract called um
with uh the home for little wanders so
um you're the
levels I think I'm looking at the right
thing um report to law enforcement is
that the page I should be looking at
it's 1172 point2
second to last page in the handout you
just gave
us there's actually a chart let the
chart um
11501 well since I have it open do can
you refer it to 1172 point2 report to
law enforcement I I'm kind of curious
what this is it's got levels too
yes it's the second to last
page
yeah yes that's currently in policy and
procedure what's in the law that we are
to verbally report to law enforcement
okay so that's what this is yes so let's
look at that for a second so it says
level one the death or presumed pending
death of a child is a critical incident
must be reported in accordance with 1099
critical incident reporting case
specific um I assume that means call
right away is that what that but now we
go down to level two and we have sexual
abused exploited physically abused uh
neglected um victim or exposed to human
trafficking this one also says will ver
verbally notify law enforcement
immediately by phone or in person when a
report is received or a new allegation
is identified in the course of the
assessment so that's also right
away um verbal notifications made to law
enforcement where the crime is believed
to have occurred that's you're saying
the local law enforcement right but yeah
I think there might be um
misunderstanding the Roman numeral one
two and three yeah aren't the levels
okay the levels are described in um
11501 report types screening decisions
and response priority
levels um and there is a chart I think
we're missing a
page I
apologize there is a chart um that
includes level one the factors of level
one the factors of level two and then
the factors of level three and those
coincide with not just state law but
federal law uh called CAPA Child Abuse
Prevention and treatment act
okay is that chart available in the on
your website or yes and um in the letter
of my written testimony I identified
each um okay with a hyperlink to the
actual DCF policy manual and identifi
the policy and Sops relating to each of
the levels and each of the response
times thank
you okay um was there anything else you
wanted to present
um if I could provide a little bit um of
explanation as well um in regard to the
prior testimony heard and certainly I'm
I can't speak about uh case specific um
examples or or um actual
cases um so when a report is screened in
and it's sent to the local office um as
uh attorney uh represented and the and
the office communicates with the local
police department it is the supervisor
so our joint protocols um through the
Attorney General's office speak to that
the supervisor at the local office is
responsible to ensure the law
enforcement notification both verbally
and in writing takes place so that is
the procedure the assigned
cpsw um to a particular investigation is
not the first Outreach to the police so
I want to make that clarification um to
our president practice and
policy
so that supervisor doesn't wait until
the caseworker goes out and comes back
with a report though right no it makes
that immediate notification upon receipt
of the information okay great further
questions representative
M so so it sounds like in in some areas
um the bill that's in front of us is
duplicative of existing statute and and
other ways it it tries to make some some
helpful uh additional Corrections that
may not be as as helpful as intended but
given the scope of the problem and given
um you know given the fact that
incidents like the harmony Montgomery
incident have happened
um what can we be doing in statute that
we're not doing now that would
help so one thing that's new in the bill
um however I do want to point out that
it's it is in our joint protocols but in
line 24 law enforcement shall not rely
on the department to gather information
for its investigation so that section is
new and is not in the statute um so that
is a a piece that I'll draw your
attention to um however the joint
protocols do outline which what each
member of the disciplinary team should
be doing so that law enforcement would
be conducting their investigation DC
would be conducting its investigation a
CAC would happen to interview the child
to minimize dup uh duplicative
interviews um and then the the parties
all work together but if I were seeing
something new this is the piece that
would be new in statute
today you just said avoiding duplicate
of interviews the police department
conduct their own interviews and
investigation in all these cases correct
they don't they don't rely on your
investigation
the way that um when children are
potentially victims of crimes um we have
um child advocacy centers set up in each
County where trained forensic
interviewers like a sane interview type
of situation yeah I get that yes so the
law enforcement would be a member of
that multi-disciplinary team at the
interview so that everyone's witnessing
that that's for they're talking about
that's related just to the victim but
what about the investigation of the home
and the parents and Witnesses the police
are still doing that themselves they're
not just taking the DCF casew workers
report correct that's what the protocols
would direct that they would do it
themselves that they would have their
own investigation thank you and we would
collaborate okay they don't have to yeah
they
do I can't imagine a prosecutor would
rely on that um wait a minute
representative Bart you had a
question yes thank you for allowing me
to ask a question and thank you for
taking my question uh if I understood
correctly within your protocol it is set
up to call the local uh law enforcement
agency and then the state police why
would we not call the sheriff's
department as the intermediate for that
county in there instead of the State
Police actually our protocol say law
enforcement agency it does not say State
Police the bill says State Police um and
that's what we are addressing in terms
that there may be some uh jur itional um
prohibit prohibitions against state
police taking ownership of a case that
they have no jurisdiction over just to
be clear State Police have jurisdiction
Statewide um I'm sorry just to be clear
the state police have jurisdiction
Statewide if they choose to exert
it but I understand what you mean about
wanting to keep it within the local
jurisdiction representative
Newell thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I just am
curious about um on lines 24 through 26
um law enforcement shall not you were
just talking about this as well shall
not rely on uh the department to gather
information I personally I work at a a
homeless shelter so I am a mandated
reporter in that way um and kind of have
been through this myself but I the the
uh process involves um the investigation
involves a lot of information that I
think is gathered by mandated reporters
along the way um in in you know history
of of different offenses and and you
know or different reports and and kind
of um to form a pattern and I'm just
wondering if something like stated the
way that it is if that would interfere
with that being a part of the um
investigation if I understand the
question are you saying that this may be
too prescriptive in terms of not
allowing law enforcement to use a piece
of I would use the phrase I guess
evidence that we collected during our
civil investigation into abuse and
neglect in their criminal case right and
I think that allows for unless such
Reliance is required or necessitated by
the standardized protocols because of
course if um for instance hypothetically
if a law enforcement agent agency is
unavailable to
um attend the CAC they're of course
going to be made aware of the CAC and
given a cop of that recorded interview
they're not going to be expected or
advised to do a reinie of a child merely
because they weren't present for That
interview if that answers your question
yeah it does thank
you but to following
that law enforcement wouldn't for
example rely on a report you
wrote if they were going to charge
somebody with a crime they would have to
do their own investigation because then
you become a fact witness to to testify
in court when well you maybe do but you
you're you you can't bring a charge so I
would they would use your report but it
would be to build their own yep thank um
no further questions thank you thank you
all for your time thank you for your um
helping us in this voluminous stuff and
I'm G look up that website um chair
calls The Honorable Erica Leon
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee um and I appreciate you taking
the time to look into this thoroughly as
I expect that you are likely aware
especially given that the vice chairman
of child and family is sitting here
today as well there are a number of
bills trying to deal with the fact that
right now it is overly difficult to get
a conviction of a parent who has caused
physical injury of their child um I'm
thankful that the criminal just Justice
committee is also looking into this
because the evidentiary standards the
due process the ability to have um
appropriate councel in interviews um is
different in the criminal system than it
is in the Civil system and I want to
ensure that there's all the protections
needed to be able to secure a conviction
of somebody who is striking their child
or sexually assaulting their child so
that we can make sure that the criminal
system also steps in when a crime
happens against a child so I thank you
for looking into
this thank
you um anybody
else anyone else wishing to testify in
this spill who hasn't done
so seeing none I here I close the public
hearing and what's our
next what is
it I hereby open a public hearing on
House Bill 445
which one is which is you yeah know
rep representative Roy if you could hold
on one second
um okay thank you uh representative
Terry Roy Rockingham 32 I'm here
introducing my bill uh 445 establishing
a study commission to examine the causes
and ways to alleviate the shortage of a
law enforcement officers in New
Hampshire um I think the members of this
committee more than anyone else probably
understand how short we are with law
enforcement in this state how difficult
it is for them to be able to attract and
keep Talent um and I think that based on
my years of experience in here um we
need to focus on this as a legislature
and see are we doing everything we can
to enable our municipalities and our
agencies to hire the best talent that's
out there we're holding our Law
Enforcement Officers to higher standard
than we ever have before which is a
great thing we want to make sure that
they have the ability to get the talent
we're demanding they have um so i' I've
put this bill together to get this
commission a a committee is too short to
even begin to work on something like
this um I have had some requests to add
a few people to this and I'm going to do
that um before we would execute I'm
going to add the um the state prison uh
commissioner and I'm going to add
sheriffs um because I seem to have
neglected them in here and I'm open to
any other suggestions um with regard to
this I just think it's a very important
thing to look at um I know money is
tight so we might not be able to throw
money at it but I've had some other
ideas for example we own a state college
um what good is owning a college if you
don't use it um we could set up a system
with UNH where new officers who sign a
contract to work at a department for a
some certain number of years could have
their tuition wave for their um law
criminal justice degree um that's just
one idea there's there's a lot of
different ideas that can be but I think
we need to examine them um so that's why
I brought this bill I'd be happy to take
any
questions representative
Muse I do have a question and and a
small amount of of of expertise and
recruiting and and things of that nature
one of the things that strikes me about
the list is the potential is there
because all of the folks are related to
to law enforcement for you guys to have
a lot of great conversations about how
bad the problem is um and maybe fewer
conversations around things to resolve
the problem I'm I'm wondering if it
would help to have somebody on the
commission who is outside of law
enforcement but who is an expert in
things like recruiting retention um and
strategies that can be employed I know
that there's a lot of interesting work
that's taken place in the last few few
years uh outside of uh state government
when it comes to this and maybe some of
that expertise could be put to use
that's a good idea it sounds expensive
but it's a good idea maybe we can start
with um State human resources and
recruiting but you're correct maybe
checking with Sherm or something like
that we might be able to get a yes yeah
representative
Matson you didn't have a question oh I'm
sorry I thought that was the thing I'm
sorry representative Shear um I think as
as uh uh chairman Roy knows
uh Manchester is down 24 officers State
Police are down 65 officers we and pouth
are down seven officers and we've been
we have a very aggressive recruiting
plan um I think you can find either at
UNH or maybe you may want to include
Southern New Hampshire in this uh
individuals who have expertise in really
what we're talking about is marketing
um um and I would
suggest something along those lines I
can talk to you about how to word
it you mean within the college system
within the the UNH the system of or
Southern New Hampshire also um they they
I know from my work as a commissioner
that we see graduates of Southern New
Hampshire also they what we're talking
about is criminal justice programs and
they have a criminal justice program
thank you so would you believe that
would be a good idea would would you
believe that that would be a good idea I
believe that would be an excellent
idea um so far from what I've got from
the committee is um some marketing and
some Human Resources suggestions I like
those um any any other questions or
suggestions because the next time you
see me on this will be with an amendment
and uh an executive
session I don't see any if you have any
and you know how to reach me um and I'd
be happy to work with anyone on the
committee interested in this
topic looks like you're off the hook
run commissioner
Hanks red is on good afternoon uh for
the Helen Hanks commissioner of the
Department of Corrections and to my
right is Captain Pete Ash a member of
our law enforcement officer rank and
file who's in his 25th year with the
Department I want to thank uh chairman
Roy and the others who uh authored this
bill and for his offering to amend it to
include the law enforcement staff at the
Department of Corrections we are here in
full support of the uh this bill and the
idea that the legislature could convene
the right Partners together to talk
about Recruitment and Retention and I
just want to um lean in a little bit too
and remember that at the high school
level there's a opportunity there as
well and we teach a an extra credit
course in Corrections both at Berlin and
gron schools and I think that there's
another space for that in this type of
commission um Captain Ash has been with
our department long enough to see what
happened before I took the helm and I
just want to give him an opportunity to
talk about his prior experience in the
things that we've done good afternoon um
I started in 1999 I was a 20 old kid um
I had a grandfather that worked in
correction so I knew a little bit about
it but didn't know what I was getting
myself into um for years we had one
security officer that was in charge of
recruiting um
and not not much help to get people in
the door so a lot of people would be in
the waiting process and find another job
um since commissioner Hanks has been on
uh she's developed stats to find out
where we're failing um over the past
several years she's been able to do a
lot of things uh as far as getting
raises for our staff which we're trying
to bring more people in we started a
recruitment retention committee um we've
expanded that and put a lot of our
officers including myself on to find out
what what it is that we can get people
to attract Corrections is not a very
attractive job a lot of people don't
understand the sacrifice that people
make um inside those walls uh it's not
something that's advertised so it's very
difficult job to recruit for but um
since Commissioners put in a lot we have
two sergeants right now that are part of
recruiting uh they go out to the schools
they go out to job fairs they go out to
events we're trying to get our ourselves
out there
so so certainly if there are any other
questions but we're really mainly here
in support of amending the bill to
include us and thanking those that
brought it forward and um I just want to
be part of the solution
Captain did you say the jobs are not
advertised if there's an opening at the
facility no they are advertised now um
years ago it was just a newspaper
article but since then we've we've had
commercials and a lot of advertisements
billboard so you said they are
advertised I'm sorry my my bad okay
representative
n thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question um I happen to know
one upand cominging um officer to be
he's my oldest um and he has for two
years been trying to get into a criminal
justice course in his high school and
they can't find a teacher to do it so
the recruitment in a variety of ways do
you think that being able to offer that
and also focusing on having criminal
justice um teachers in the schools would
be
helpful uh represent new I think that's
a great idea again to Captain Ash's
point a lot of people don't know what we
do in corrections as a form of law
enforcement in New Hampshire and um as
one component of the justice system
we're missing an opportunity to teach
our young people what those are and how
to pave a path post high school and some
of those opportunities can happen right
after high school and some could happen
in collaboration with our University and
college systems thank you thank
you uh I don't need specific numbers but
I'm curious uh to what degree you're
able to hire people from out of state or
is the hiring mostly of instate
people represent Shar that's a great
question we have some individuals that
are coming from out ofate we did a
pretty assertive marketing campaign uh
understanding our I'll call it our
digital audience so whether it was
Facebook or Instagram who's looking at
our page and we had a contracted
marketing partner for a short period of
time um so we did draw some people from
New York uh we drew some people from
Vermont and Maine and we are actually
interestingly enough drawing some people
out of Massachusetts the furthest away
we drew someone to move to New Hampshire
was Montana
followup um have you had any sex success
with uh lateral
hires um put outside the from outside
the
state I want to make sure I understand
your question when you say the term
lateral hire people who are already
Corrections Officers in other states uh
we have had some success there uh want
to just say there not every state has
their Corrections Officers as certified
law enforcement um so we drawn the
individual from Montana worked in the
Montana Department of Corrections we
still put them through our Corrections
Academy we've hired an individual from
Vermont Department of Corrections U so
we get some spots of those that re uh
locate to New Hampshire one one last
followup um to what extent are are do
you get hire people who are leaving a
police department uh that is a more rare
occurrence we do on occasion we have a
full-time person who retired from a
local municipality up north who then now
works at our Corrections Department
fulltime thank you for those questions
representative
Murphy thank you madam chair um thank
you commissioner um I'm I represent the
town of marac and in March we have um
our Police Department uh has created an
uh ELO Extended Learning opportunity for
uh students interest in criminal justice
I wonder I mean I know it's early it's
not quite like an nhti program that
would maybe lead to something else but
would there any be any value in working
um looking to see where you guys can um
establish a relationship with those high
schools throughout the state that have
those kind of um Extended Learning
opportunities and if not encouraging
them as to how that might be the the
routine you know the the the gateway to
those the other our our um State
programs for education in that program
you representative Murphy that's exactly
what we're doing up in the north uh
region and we would love those to expand
themselves I think for us as a
department we're not the experts in how
to navigate that relationship I think
this commission could help us understand
how to do that better and consistently
across those uh high school programs and
other programs that want to offer
it thank
you I don't see any more questions but I
I do have a question
myself my clerk has inform me that she
thinks that this is Miss Graham's
handwriting was this you commissioner or
is this the neatest handwriting I've
ever seen in my entire life like she
didn't even use the lines y'all and she
is exactly like straight across she I
need to go to I wow she uh she may be
one of the best people I know and her
handwriting being the best does not
surprise me ma'am holy wow go you miss
Graham okay thank you everyone thank you
for coming today appreciate it
is there
[Music]
any is there anybody else here wishing
to testify on House Bill 445 that has
not turned in the pink card seeing none
I will close the public hearing and our
next
hearing is at 3:15 buckle up it'll be a
long one buckle
up
e
e e
good afternoon everybody if you could
please um take your seats get yourself
situated we are going to open the public
hearing for house bill um
159 um after the sponsor introduces the
bill we do have not a ton of cards but a
decent amount we are going to limit
testimony to 3 minutes we would ask that
if the person before you or at any time
before you says what you were going to
say if you could just yield um if they
do say the same thing it means that they
did a really good job so just give them
a high five and say thank you um at this
time I am opening the the public hearing
for houseb 159 and invite the prime
sponsor to introduce his
legislation thank you madam chairman and
members of the committee uh
representative Roy Rockingham 32 I am
here introducing House Bill 159 house
ball 159 is um related to House Bill
1711 from last year that I brought that
cleared the house and it um died in the
Senate over the summer um I was
contacted by the nephew of Chief ha the
um security officer who was murdered at
the New Hampshire hospital last year and
he asked me to refile the
legislation um I've been working with
the um National Rifle Association um to
make some changes to the bill um and
I've heard from various members of the
house and I've made some changes based
on that so um I have passed out an
amendment what I've taken out of the
bill was the confiscation piece um so
what it said before was once you were
notified by the court that you had been
um that you had been committed uh for
being um dangerously mentally ill to
yourself or others the court would
notify you that you were now a
prohibited person per federal law and
state law and you had to turn over your
weapons and and that um was causing a
lot of um consternation among the public
and other members because frankly
weapons are very expensive and we just
don't really feel comfortable with them
going into what would appear to be a
black Cole and no one knows where they
were going to go so we took that piece
out to get that complication out but
what it now reads is the court will warn
the person you are not supposed to have
firearms and you may transfer those
Firearms to someone else or to a a
licensed um dealer or or if you have no
one else you can give them to the police
but it's not
mandatory so I took that out so just to
start with the bill what the bill does
is currently there's 48 states in the
country 48 States and um the District of
Columbia and Puerto Rico whereby they
they follow the the federal law where
that says that if you you become a
prohibited person from owning a firearm
if you are found by a court of competent
jurisdiction to be a danger to
yourselves or others and you are
committed to involuntarily to a mental
institution
um those States and territories other
than us notify NX when that happens so
what NX is is his ini National inst
criminal background check system that
was actually instituted many many years
ago at the request of the NRA because it
used to take um sometimes weeks and
months to be able to buy a firearm so
they came up the out dive Nicks
instantly so that people could instantly
get their firearms so it was a a
cooperation between all of the states
because it doesn't work if the states
don't work with it all the information
in Nick doesn't come from the federal
government it comes from the states so
when you are convicted of a felony
that's submitted to ncks um no matter
what state you're in um if there's a a a
restraining order or order protective
protective order against you that's put
into Nicks that's part of that agreement
and you are blocked from buying a
firearm so in 48 other
states they report when someone has been
found a danger to themselves or others
and committed in New Hampshire we don't
do that and because of that and I can
say this clearly now because it's been
proven Chief ha is dead the person that
shot him had been committed twice he
should have been reported and after he
was committed he went to a store in New
Hampshire he purchased firearms and he
went and murdered chiefa now can I say
that it it wouldn't have happened
otherwise that he might have got them
some other way possibly but that's not
what happened what happened was is he
went to a store and bought them and he
was able to do so because we did not
report him another thing that's very
concerning is um we could be the problem
for someone else New Hampshire doesn't
have a wall around it people can leave
so when you're committed and you're
mentally ill and you're prohibited you
might decide I'm just going to pack up
and move to Texas and you get to Texas
and you go buy a firearm and then you
stop taking your medication and things
aren't going so well for you anymore and
you start hearing voices again because
you may have schizophrenia or or some
other um illness and you shoot someone
down there well what they it's going to
come out that person came from New
Hampshire where we don't report um so
that's problematic because the rest of
the states are are playing by the rules
that we all agreed to and we were
deciding no we're not going to so that
that's troubling um for many reasons
so a lot of people I've been getting
hundreds of hundreds of emails maybe you
have too that keep saying don't do this
there's no due process this law is
literally replete with du process in
order to be found
um dangerous to yourselves or others and
committed you have to go through a
hearing and it it's in the statute it's
so clear you have to go before a judge
you are assigned an attorney if you
can't afford one um you are allowed to
cross-exam and Witnesses you are allowed
to put on Witnesses your own defense you
are allowed to appeal his ruling it is
the very definition of due process so no
one's rights are being taken without due
process and frankly we're not taking
anyone's rights anyway it's the the very
instant that judge says you are
committed by federal law your rights are
suspended now another important piece
that the emails don't seem to mention is
that I've put for the first time in our
New Hampshire statutes a way to restore
your rights currently there are people
in New Hampshire hundreds of them who
cannot buy a firearm because they were
found dangerous um by their doctor you
can be put on this list and people don't
people don't often realize this this
isn't the only way to get on that list
is the commitment part another part is
doctors are mandated reporters and if
you go to your doctor and you're talking
to them and you tell them that you've
been thinking about hurting someone or
yourself and they think it's credible
they're mandated to report that to the
Department of Safety and they do and you
go on the list because they're not
that's not protected what is protected
in our statute is these hearings um for
commitment that's the reason that we
need this law because it's Supreme Court
said that the commitment hearings had
such privacy um built into them that we
couldn't report it without the statute
so there's people in New Hampshire right
now who cannot buy firearms because
their doctor said at one point in their
life they were dangerous to themselves
or others and it was reported now maybe
they had a bad time bad weekend bad year
and they're better now well that's too
bad they can't get it back the federal
law will not allow a person's name to
come off that list unless the state has
in statute what's called a restoration
of Rights process and in that you have
to go before a judge and you have to
have a doctor say that you are no longer
a danger and once you do that you can
get your rights back but currently in
New Hampshire it's a life sentence you
are never going to own a gun again
legally so just to sum it
up this would law if it passes would
affect such a minuscule population it's
people who have been committed to a
mental institution
involuntarily and so that means not
folks who who went to the doctor and
said I need help or checked in
themselves to get help
involuntarily committed after having a
due process hearing where they are had
an
attorney their name will be reported to
Nicks and they cannot buy a firearm or
possess a
firearm this law also gives them hope
where they have n now where they could
get their rights back when they're
better have the doctor say this person
is no longer a danger and then they can
go back to court with that letter and
say your honor I'm better and they can
get their rights back so it it does two
things um and with that I'd be happy to
take any
questions representative
Muse I do have a a quick question about
your your Amendment as I understand your
Amendment um it would allow somebody in
this situation to voluntarily relinquish
their firearms but what it would do is
it would remove um the clause in the
prior bill that that allowed uh Law
Enforcement Officers to confiscate those
weapons after 48 hours is that correct
that's correct the it removes the the
confiscation the forceful taking of the
weapons by law enforcement is totally
gone out of it now
now it's left to the judge to work out
with the person um or their family
however they can work it out whether the
person has firearms and they get those
Firearms safely taken somewhere else the
police are taken out of that followup
follow what if the person just simply
decides that they are not going to agree
to relinquish their
firearms that is then um well that
depends it's not the law does the
statute doesn't contemplate that so
I mean if the person says I have
firearms and I'm not giving them to you
that would be between them and the the
law enforcement who they say that in
front of I guess um that they've
admitted they're a prohibited person
with Firearms what this does is it PR it
prohibits the police from going to
people's house and starting look around
for their firearms or if someone says I
think he's got guns and the police be
able to go look for him so it's it's
it's going to a um it's going to a place
where the people hopefully are going to
be honest with the the with the the
court or hopefully their family members
will help them and get those Firearms
out of the house if they have some I
think we're looking at this point more
proactively let's see if we can before
these folks actually purchase firearms
which is the really Crux of this bill is
to keep people from going out after this
happens and be able to purchase
firearms thank
you everybody
good seeing no further questions thank
you very much
Dr
strank pardon me if you could if you
could just hit the button so the red
light it's actually opposite red means
red means go here I'm an Emergency
Physician with 35 years of practice
experience in the field and I'm here to
testify against this poorly warted and
dangerous bill this bill would allow the
state of New Hampshire and then by
report the federal government to be in
possession of confidential personal
Mental Health Data the authors try to
claim that it doesn't but in fact it
does three times before you even get to
the text of the bill it states quote an
act authorizing the state to report
Mental Health Data end quote or quote
this bill authorizes the state to report
Mental Health Data end quote three times
it states that just at the very
beginning allowing any government for
legal purposes to be in possession of
private medical information shielded by
the long revered and protected principle
of Dr patient confidentiality should put
shivers down your spine section 159g
colon 2 lists three distinct criteria
which would allow the state using
confidential mental health information
to revoke someone's second amendment
rights all three criteria are most often
temporary in nature for example an
elderly man loses his wife and now
suddenly as a widower is so consumed by
grief that he wants to die and join her
in heaven family or perhaps a neighbor
calls the police who bring him to the
emergency room for
evaluation this is what I see regularly
in my work he is in evaluated by a
mental health crisis counselor whereupon
he repeats his desire to die and
therefore is committed involuntarily to
a mental health facility and in doing so
his Firearms are taken away he could
give them to a family member but he has
no choice in that matter the state will
determine if they are surrendered to a
federally licensed Firearms dealer and
if they are he must pay to have them
restored which is a violation of his
Fifth Amendment rights against the
unjust taking of private property
returning to my example in just two
weeks counseling and perhaps an
anti-depressant has helped him to
resolve his reactive depression and
that's an actual medical diagnosis and
is very easy to understand and he is
cleared for release home but now he must
embark on a fight to restore his right
to keep and bear arms as guaranteed
under the Second Amendment this brings
us to the chap to the chapter 159 G6
exclusions section of this bill chapter
159 G colon 6 Roman numeral 1 States
quote neither the court nor the
department of safety shall transmit
information on Persons seeking voluntary
treatment or on Persons involuntarily
hospitalized for assessment or
evaluation now the authors of this bill
may have meant to write voluntarily
hospitalized instead of
involuntarily but as written this
language is in direct contradiction to
section
159 G2 Roman numeral 3 where it states
an involuntary hospitalization will in
fact cause someone to lose their second
amendment rights it can can't be both
does everyone see that contradictory
language or do you need me to explain
that
further in seeking relief he would now
have to petition the court whereupon an
independent psychiatric evaluation would
determine if he is allowed to once again
exercise his second amendment rights but
who determines who this independent
psychiatrist is the bill does not say
but it appears to be the court would any
of you if accused of a crime think it
fair if the jury was chosen only by the
prosec
that your defense attorney has no say in
the matter I as much as we would love to
hear the rest of what you have to say we
do have a three minute time limit I'm
almost
done okay but we already I already let
you go over about 25 seconds so thank I
I have written testimony I'd be happy to
provide a copy for all of you that would
be fantastic thank you very much okay
thank you just a friendly reminder
everybody we do have a a three minute
time limit I'm doing everything I can to
to stick to that
Kathleen
Slover hello my name is Kathleen Slover
I'm from Portsmouth New Hampshire and
I'm representing myself um even though
federal law prohibits people with
certain types of mental health
adjudications to possess and purchase
firearms the federal law cannot require
state to make information identifying
these people available so it's up to the
states and a lot of the states moved the
needle in
2007 when a Virginia Tech student shot
and killed
32 people and injured 17 others Before
Dying by suicide on the college campus
of blackburg
Virginia the gunman was in fact
prohibited from purchasing a firearm
under federal law because of a history
of Mental Illness but was able to
purchase firearms after two background
checks Virginia increased its reporting
of mental health records and it resulted
in blocking other gun sales in Virginia
for the next few years um in from 2007
to 2010 there was a 47%
increase um it's up to the states to
take the
responsibility it's by federal law so I
hope that you um
pass
uh support this Bill thank
you Miss
Reynolds hi Kristen Reynolds from
Swansea New Hampshire
uh I moved from Portland a few years ago
and I had there some some experiences
that really changed the way I thought
about gun laws previously I would have
supported a gun law like this but then I
lived through some things and I wanted
to just share
them so in Portland in
2020 with the lockdowns we had
chaos and the police were not coming to
people's homes to help
them and the gangs were
out and I had gunshots all around my
apartment
constantly so I learned when there's
chaos when there's a problem the police
aren't necessarily there to help
me that was one
lesson the second lesson I
learned also during that time was it's
amazing what can become a mental
illness people who did not decide to
take the experimental vaccine were
suddenly thought of as mentally ill
so it's very
concerning because it can become very
political who's who's mentally ill and
who's not mentally ill so I learned that
second lesson third
lesson my son when he was 25 living in
an apartment in
Portland with housemates has someone
just walk into his
home come up the
stairs and go straight towards his
female
housemate he ran into his room got his
pistol pointed it at the
guy guy
left that was a very powerful lesson and
since that time I have support guns and
when I moved here to New Hampshire and
everybody has a
gun surprisingly I felt the safest I
ever felt in my
life so there you have it I am opposed
to this
thank you very
much Miss
Moren happy
Friday I'm testifying on behalf of the
women's Defense League um this bill is
an emotional knee-jerk reaction to the
horrible murder of a former law
enforcement officer turned unarmed
security guard at the state psychiatric
facility there's nothing in this bill
that would have PR present uh prevented
that tragedy there's nothing in this
bill that stops VI even with the new
Amendment there's nothing in this bill
that stops violently mentally ill people
from committing criminal acts against
their innocent victims and I haven't had
um a chance to really review the bill
and go through all the words but even
the amendment still intentionally
discriminates against gun owners it's
the different language same outcome and
there are many cases of mass criminal
acts committed by the violently mentally
ill where Firearms are not the object
chosen why aren't matches lighters
knives automobiles pressure cookers or
other objects being confiscated or
turned in as well gun control laws such
as this one do not stop criminals from
either getting Firearms illegally or
from using other objects to commit
violent acts a US Department of Justice
report from 2016 shows that a majority
of imprisoned Crim criminals obtain
their firearms illegally this bill does
nothing to stop that reporting this info
does nothing to stop that this bill does
nothing to stop violently mentally ill
people from committing any crimes if
someone is violently mentally ill why
are they living in society why aren't
they in safe facilities where they
cannot hurt themselves or others I'll
answer for you because psychiatrist lied
into told a politicians years ago that
violently mentally ill people would be
just fine in society if they only took
drugs that were untested in long-term
clinical trials politicians believe them
and shut down mental health facilities
across the country this project was an
abject failure failure in many ways but
most importantly violently mentally ill
people do not get the help they leave
and are living need and are living in
society where they have easy access to
act out their violent aggressions
against innocent victims this bill does
nothing to resolve that this bill still
points the finger at gun owners and the
reality is the finger should be pointed
back at the psychiatrists who pushed for
this failure and the New Hampshire
legislator for doing nothing to remedy
or solve the actual issue in regards to
violently mentally ill people we need to
have more mental health facilities open
so these people can live out their lives
safely and safe from society and they
know on the side a majority of those
with mental illness are more likely to
be victims and criminals this is
referring to people who are diagnosed as
violently mentally
ill please vote in expedient to
legislate on this bill nothing is being
solved with this bill not even with what
I've read from the new Amendment we need
legislators with courage to stand up and
work on the real problem of violently
mentally ill people in our society thank
you thank you very
much Miss Thurber
um hello my name is Simon Thurber I'm
from exitor New Hampshire um according
to the current federal law people are
inv voluntarily committed um people who
are involuntarily committed to a
psychiatric facility are are already
prohibited from possessing or purchasing
a firearm however in New Hampshire
current however New Hampshire currently
does not report those cases to NX or the
national um instant criminal background
check system thus making National
firearm background checks inaccurate
incomplete and
ineffective House Bill 159 would close
this glaring and dangerous
loophole um when last year's version of
this bill was being considered in
2024 Governor sonunu uh who as you know
is a big supporter of uh gun rights uh
he supported the passage of the bill and
according to the nhp article from May
17th 2024 sununu said this is clearly a
loophole that has to be closed and I'm
supportive of the bill uh please vote in
support of House Bill 159 thank you
thank you very
much Dr
Hank good afternoon uh my name is Dr
John Hanam representing the New
Hampshire Psychiatric Society and the
New Hampshire Medical Society and both
societies strongly support House Bill
159 as as important legislation to
reduce the Public Health crisis of gun
violence in our
society I worked as a psychiatrist at
New Hampshire hospital for many years
and I was working at New Hampshire
hospital on November 17th when gunshots
were heard in our
lobby all the patients and staff at New
Hampshire hospital had to shelter in
place because there was an active
shooter in the building only later I
found that security officer Bradley hos
had died
heroically while protecting all the
patients and staff at New Hampshire
hospital after the tragedy at New
Hampshire hospital the state
investigated what
happened and the Attorney General office
released a report regarding their
investigation they determined that the
gunman had a history of mental
illness and had been a patient at New
Hampshire hospital previously they
determined that the gunman had purchased
the pistol from a gun dealer in
barington New Hampshire after affirming
that he had never been committed to a
mental
institution so it was determined that
the gunman who fatally shot Chief hos
had obtained the weapon after lying
about his own mental health history on
the federal firearm
application clearly the current system
is not working and chief hos and the
gunman died as a result if the gunman's
Mental Health Data had been reported to
the National instant check system this
tragedy may have been
prevented when a tragedy like this
occurs it is the responsibility of our
elected leaders to investigate what
caused the tragedy and to fix the
problem so it will not happen
again House Bill 159 is a solution to
this
problem in closing gun violence is a
Public Health crisis and the New
Hampshire Psychiatric Society and
Medical
Society strongly support House Bill
159 as a way to potentially reduce the
risks of suicide and homicide in the
state of New Hampshire
thank you and I'm happy to take any
questions see no questions thank you
very much thank
you Holly Stevens
Madam chair members of the committee my
name is Holly Stevens and I'm the
director of public policy for Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness on behalf of Nami New
Hampshire I'm here today to offer
cautious support for houseu
159 yesterday at our legislative
breakfast we were asked why Nami New
Hampshire was offering cautious support
for a bill that would impact a
constitutional right of someone with a
mental illness rather than summarizing
my written testimony about the different
Protections in the bill I'm going to
answer this question for you
today and let you read about the
protections that Nami New Hampshire
feels are important at your
leisure Nami New Hampshire is cautiously
supportive of this bill because of the
impact it will have on suicide
approximately 85% of all attempts made
with a firearm are fatal Firearms are
the most common method used in suicide
attempts and in the grand State 87% of
all gun deaths are suicide deaths
compared to 56% nationally and I also
wanted to talk with you about the iea
process and how it relates to this
bill first a petition is completed by
the petitioner and a medical provider
and then it is signed by a judge or a
Justice of the pece at this point the
person is transported to New Hampshire
hospital or another designated receiving
facility this bill does not affect
people who are simply the subject of an
IA petition and transported to the
hospital this is part of the evaluation
and assessment process a person can be
held for 72 hours once the Ia petition
is completed during the 72 hours a
probable cause hearing must be held to
determine if the person can be held
beyond the 72-hour period and for up to
10 days each person is represented by
councel during this probable cause
hearing if the court finds probable
cause to continue the hospitalization
the person can be kept through those 10
days again this is also part of that
assessment and evaluation process this
bill does not affect these people who
have had a probable cause hearing and
have been found for them to be kept up
through that 10 days after 10 days if
the hospital Personnel believed the
person is still not safe to be
discharged a probate commitment is held
to determine if the person can be held
at the hospital for up to 5
years the person is also represented by
council at this hearing the bill only
affects the people who the court
determines can continue to be held
involuntarily beyond the 10 days and for
up to 5 years to be clear it is not all
people subject to an iea
also at any time during the Ia process a
person can decide to remain at the
hospital on a voluntary basis they can
change their minds and so long as that
happens before that probate that second
hearing
happens this bill would have zero impact
on
them that was just where I was ending um
I hope that helps you understand why we
are cauly supportive of this
Bill thank you very much
honorable Jr
Hall just be before you before you again
um I just want to remind everybody there
was an amendment pass out just so
everybody that maybe does not have that
knows that
now whenever you're ready sure thank you
madam chair um for the record I have not
Jr hole town of dun Barton representing
the New Hampshire Firearms Coalition um
I have not seen the amendment yet so I'm
going to speak to the bill as filed um
fundamentally the bill itself is so
flawed that I'm not sure an amendment
can fix it and I will say that again the
bill and the concept is so fundamentally
flawed that there is no way to fix it
with an amendment
New Hampshire Firearms Coalition opposes
HB 159 the bill is a red flag bill under
the guise of a mental health it is the
same bill that was filed last year
almost verbatim with one word change as
HB
1711 this bill attempts to capitalize on
the murder of a retired police chief um
Captain or officer hos the bill would
allow psychologists and state
bureaucrats to strip law-abiding
citizens of their constitutional second
amendment
rights first the B the bill violates two
provisions of the New Hampshire
Constitution Article
14 by having no recourse right every
subject in the state is entitled to
certain remedy having recourse to the
loss for all injuries he may receive in
person property or character to obtain
right and Justice freely without being
obligated to purchase it if a person is
being stripped of their rights do they
have to go hire the attorney or is the
state going to provide the attorney and
pay reasonable attorneys fees so that
they can be represented in a court
during this process
secondly it also violates Article 15
that no subject shall be held to answer
for any crime going on to spoiled or
deprived of his property the way the
process is laid out in the bill their
firearms are taken or removed without
any
say Additionally the bill attempts to
use the fundamental broken criminal
database in the packet that I handed out
there was a report from 2018 relative to
Nicks and this was put out by the
government accountability office in the
the 8.6 million transactions they denied
112,000 people of that 112,000 people
they investigated a mere 12,000 so
roughly 10% and of those they only
prosecuted 12 so of the 112,000 people
that were denied the chance to buy a
firearm and it's a felony if you are a
prohibited person attempting to buy a
firearm they prosecuted 12 this isn't
obviously a deterrent so there are
fundamental processes that that are
broken within the Nick system the
database is corrupt people are
wrongfully denied
routinely next using a criminal database
the national instant criminal database
to track mental health is wrong it is
simply wrong to put mental health
information and people who are having
mental health issues into a criminal
database it potentially affects
employment long term and it potentially
affects other things that may go on in
their life we should not do that
the potential issue of a person being so
dangerous and needing to be put in a
criminal database because of a mental
health issue would be better resolved by
getting them the help they need through
the mental health system as opposed to
taking away their constitutionally
protected rights next there's an email
floating around in response to our
emails that says you have to be
involuntarily committed for 30 days to
trigger this mechanism that is not what
the bill reads if you listen to the
speaker before me there are Provisions
within the mental health statutes under
135 c34 35 36 and probably some sections
earlier that there is a process defined
none of it is 30 days
long next although the federal law right
can you get your rights restored there's
a section in this bill that says you can
although federal law provides for a
means of release from Firearms I'm I'm
quoting the ATF I sent you the copy
atf's annual appropriation since October
of 1992 has proh prohibited the
expending of any funds to investigate or
act upon the applications for for Relief
that means once you go into the system
you're stuck let's not do that let's not
do that to our mental health people
struggling with mental health issues
lastly in closing if a person was truly
a risk to others this will do nothing to
stop them from harming others if that is
their intention as we' have seen in
recent events vehicle
homicides that showed up more recently
in the news right people can be harmed
okay do we stop people from buying cars
just because they have been used to
commit
homicides as I pointed out in my notes
the state has no duty to protect under
Castle Rock V Gonzalez and for those not
familiar with the case I'm going to read
quickly the summary of the article right
this is a case from 2005 in a 72
decision where a lady tried to get her
estranged husband a restraining order
and he murdered her three
children she took the town to court
because obviously the police had a duty
to enforce the restraining order and the
Supreme Court of the United States said
there is no Duty for the state to
protect
somebody that is left up to the
individual this bill harms the gun
owners harms the citizens in New
Hampshire I would ask that you'd find it
inexp to legislate thank
you just in time just in
time see no questions thank you very
much
Dr
feder hello my name's um Jeffrey feder
I'm chief medical officer at New
Hampshire hospital um and I've testified
here under various hats but today under
the Hat of um being a member of the New
Hampshire Medical and psychiatric
societies um I you to support
hr19 I was at um New Hampshire hospital
during the shooting and I'm not going to
recap that story except to say that we
do now know that um the individual uh
lied about their um mental status
history but I actually mostly think
about this bill as a suicide prevention
Bill New Hampshire had 134 suicides in
2022 the last uh good uh data year that
I'm able to access that's one suicide by
firearm one suicide by firearm every 3
days in New
Hampshire what we do know is that
preventing access to the preferred
method of suicide prevents total
suicides this is a non-controversial
piece of science at this point it's on
my board exam I have to take every 10
years that when they cut off the ability
for people to kill themselves by cold
gas in England
um almost 100 years ago now suicide
rates went down when they put fences up
around a bridge that people like to jump
off as a suicide uh spot they didn't
move to the next Bridge a couple blocks
down cutting off the preferred method of
suicide does not allow people to just do
it some other way it really
matters when illegal guns are prevalent
in society people might reasonably ask
what good does a bill like this do but
it's important to remember that folks
with mental illness are not mostly
criminals they would feel just as weird
as you or I walking onto the street
corner and trying to buy an illegal gun
cutting off the preferred means if that
is to buy a legal gun would matter as a
suicide prevention
tactic um on a couple of technical
issues people ask what psychiatrists
would do this the courts do have a pool
of psychiatrist they use for involuntary
commitment hearings I imagine that would
be the same group of independent
contracted psychiatrists they would
use um on the confidentiality piece I'd
Point your attention to um uh the
language that the person's name and
identifier signifying their applicable
prohibition under 18 USC 922g social
security number and data birth would be
submitted none of that is confidential
medical information it would not count
as um protected health information under
under
Hippa
um it's often said in the wake of a a
shooting that we ought to not pass more
laws but enforce existing laws that's
exactly what this does the Brady Bill
made that shooter a prohibited person
and we did not enforce it the state
should enforce that
bill finally I would just mention that
it's often said that when these attacks
happen there's a call to strengthen
Mental Health Systems I agree after
having worked all throughout this mental
health system in this State strengthen
the mental health system by giving it
one more tool the ability to report
people we know to be dangerous and the
police don't yet now thank you Dr feder
um I see a lot of guests here that have
not turned in a a card if you do intend
to speak on this bill please do so now
because we are getting down to um the
last few and we're trying very hard to
do uh support oppose support
oppose Mr simkin
good
afternoon Madame chairwoman and members
of the committee thank you for hearing
my testimony I am a federally licensed
Firearms dealer I'm exempt from the
Nicks process so I don't have a horse in
the race for that reason
key
points one firearm abundance makes HB
159 FN bluntly put a waste of time as at
end 2023 there were approximately 512
million firearms in the United
States in my written testimony a copy of
which I will provide to each member of
the committee I explain what that number
comprehends but there's roughly 1.6
firearms for every human resident in the
US including infants who typically don't
own much second Chief hos was murdered
because Dartmouth Hitchcock forced him
to be disarmed he wasn't shot from
behind and I've read the Attorney
General's
report the murderer acquired the firearm
about three years before he abused it to
murder Chief hos Chief ha was basically
made a Sitting Duck by someone at Dart
Dartmouth Hitchcock and this committee
ought to find out who that was third
Point HB 159 offers fictive Pathways for
one adjudicated to regain the Civil
Right to be armed and the reason is that
first of all
critically a person who is involuntarily
committed is not likely to have the
money to hire an attorney of their
choice and to be and to fund that
attorneys hiring a an expert
psychiatrist so the state needs to
provide that money so that one who is
inv voluntarily committed has a zealous
attorney to defend them what is in HB
1559 doesn't do
that
fourth the federal authorities cannot be
made to Del list anyone from a
prohibited person's database it's called
the supremacy clause of the sixth
amendment
so those who tell you that a person's
name once put into the database can be
taken
out I'll leave it to this way the green
leafy stuff they sprinkled on their
breakfast pizza may have looked like
oregano but it
wasn't fifth Federal Federal authorities
have specifically
rejected a state's restoration of the
Civil Right to be armed I have personal
direct knowledge because I appeared
before the New Hampshire Supreme Court
as a non-attorney representative for
such a person he had his civil right to
be armed restored by
Massachusetts the feds told
Massachusetts decades after
Massachusetts so enacted no we don't
respect
that as Tony Mr simin one more Point
Madam chairman Mr simin your time is up
thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for giving me the
opportunity attorney Dean
my
[Laughter]
girl that would be
him put the bill on top of that
so miss Dean we're just going to go
ahead and get yourself um settled we're
going to just wait a minute for this to
come around because I don't I don't want
to distract from um testimony while this
is being passed
out
okay each of you should get two did you
have to take out a finance to print all
that turn on your mic she's she's hold
on one second we're not ready yet well
she was talking to try and get oh
well they would they weren't
that's the this packet isn't from you
not the the mine have two pink sheets on
oh that packet's not mine
okay I I see that now okay I can see
that you know you only needed to finance
half of that packet I understand well no
there's still two good siiz pig ones for
each person so and come on I was trying
to throw you a bone thank you you
know I bought stock and Xerox in HP last
year
so everybody please take not it's hot
pink the very best color
all
right all right all right two packets
here we go oh my God
almost used to be
the all right everybody you guys ready
oh yeah all right all
right okay when over you're ready good
morning members of the committee my name
is Penny Dean And for those of you that
don't know me I'm a private attorney
solo practitioner based in conquered New
Hampshire and I happen to love guns and
love firearms and and I'm very very
fortunate to make a living doing the
things I love there is so much bad about
this bill that I had to give you two
packets and I can't even begin even if
we were here all night to tell you
what's wrong with it and I start off
with you always got to put yourself in
the other man's shoes and having grown
up dirt poor and being abused by
authorities I can usually put myself in
the other guy's shoes cuz I've we've
been there and so you ask yourself how
is this going to work for me in one of
the packets I gave you if you notice
there's two pages it's from the New
Hampshire bar news and the New Hampshire
bar news said and this was a 2023 print
out that there were 2200 ieas that year
now I have been trying to find out for
years and years and years just a number
not docket numbers or anything and you
can get the combination to Fort Knox
easier cuz I haven't been able to get
numbers that I feel are good and
reliable you know and so and they were
begging lawyers because there's not
enough lawyers to represent those people
so tell me what we're going to do now
but the other thing is as an attorney
who's been there conducting or
representing people these hearings they
expect you 15 minutes max and if you
think you want to take a half hour or an
hour the world's going to end there
they're going to F throw a fit so think
about it 15 minutes to decide whether or
not you get locked away think just put
yourself in the shoes but here's what's
worse they use this term about
independent medical exam let me
translate that into
English here's what happens they have
their preferred
people and for example the one that I
used to deal with was a Dr Joffrey
Barnett and he was the one when they
bring them in they this is for the court
it's independent well if it's
independent yeah right but then I got
looking around the doctor at the time
now they've changed their website was
the director of aware Recovery Care and
that place just happened to have all
sorts of courses and places that you
could get treatment for if you wanted to
get out of there think about that for a
minute and ask yourself if you want
those quote independent
people making decisions about your life
I can tell you there used to be a couple
people in the state who will do these
type of things who are fair-minded
you're looking at $20,000 for an exam
and report and come in and testify and
you ask yourself in addition to a lawyer
if you've got that type of money most
people don't especially at the worst
time of their life when these type of
things
happen so you go down the list but
here's what's most important to me
they're putting out this carrot we've
got a way for you to get your rights
back and I'm just a dumb country girl
and I think about things about how they
go mechanically and so I want you to
really look at the packet that I put out
for you and look secondly at the
petition for rid of C that was filed by
the New Hampshire attorney general which
I found incredibly offensive when my
client's rights were restored by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court the our New
Hampshire attorney general applied to
the United States Supreme Court for rid
of sority to have it overr one more
second and then I'll
you're going to tell us where to go to
in here right um it's the whole package
it's the petition and and so if you ask
why it's funny printed like that the UN
the United States Supreme Court requires
it to be printed like that okay but what
happened that I was told was quite
unusual we were ordered by the Supreme
Court to wrate a brief in opposition to
write a petition in opposition I was
just going to wait to see if the court
accepted the case and the court said Oh
no you're going to write one in
opposition so I'm happy to answer
questions there's so many procedural
things wrong but it's it's
horrible I don't I don't see any
questions but um we have your certainly
have your telephone number you made
available and if anybody does have any
questions I'm sure you're okay if they
yeah absolutely no I'm happy to answer
questions
right well seeing none thank you very
much thank you for coming in today Dr
Hannon
we good all right you're all set thank
you all right um my name is Joe Hannon
I'm the vice president for guns of New
Hampshire I'm uh speaking in opposition
to House Bill 159 uh it's I I don't want
to speak to the amendment because we
haven't really had time I I do
appreciate getting it just prior to this
um I'm not going to repeat a lot of
things that were said I'd like to talk
about a couple of other things that I
don't believe were mentioned a lot um
you know we heard about the
burdensomeness invasiveness and
potentially discouraging um potentially
discouraging individuals from seeking
mental health treatment uh that's
something that if people are worried
about people getting the care the need
and getting mental treat mental health
treatment this is something that can
actually prohibit people from wanting to
come forward if they're worried about
what's going to happen to me and it
doesn't necessarily have to be for guns
it could be for any number of of things
um we also have uh to worry about the
disparity of subgroups of people who are
not as easily able to get back their
rights to have rights restored if there
is a process that actually works um you
know it comes down to money it comes
down to access and information not
everyone's going to be treated the same
with getting their rights back if
someone has a million dollars in the
bank it's not going to be a big deal if
someone's homeless or poor it's
definitely going to be an
obstacle
um
uh last and also I want to mentioned
that um you know I'm not speaking ill of
Psychiatry or mental health some of my
good friends and people I associate with
are in those fields but I I would like
to say that the history of mental
illness being used to as U as in a sense
being weaponized uh so to speak is is
not is not something new um different
mental illnesses that are not considered
criminal or or mental illnesses even now
were on the books for a long time
homosexuality up until 1973 was
classified as a mental illness by the
APA hysteria in the 19th and 20th
centuries women exhibiting symptoms like
anxiety fainting and nervousness were
often diagnosed with this and
institutionalized epilepsy people were
often viewed as criminally or as
possessed or criminally insane and led
to their confinement in asylums same
with
alcoholism uh leading to
institutionalization mental health in
general uh many behaviors that were
considered or labeled mental illness
leading to widespread
institutionalization without proper
diagnosis or treatment I'm not saying
we're not diagnosing and treating people
as properly today it's obviously many
improvements have been made but things
change over time what may be considered
a problem today may not be considered a
problem in 20 or 30 or 40 years from now
um I also don't think it's it's it's
important that
um that we don't make some of the
mistakes that we had with ourselves in
New Hampshire we if people remember the
Laconia school there was a big far big
property in in The Lakes Region that
housed people with mental illness
alcoholism epilepsy uh people that they
just thought weren't of you know the
right moral character all kinds of
illnesses and diagnoses were used to put
people in an institution um I don't know
I'm don't want to get in debate about
what's you know what do we do with these
individuals you know we've heard lock
them up we've heard different things but
I think that's beyond the scope of what
we're doing today I think we have to
realize that we've had an absolutely
horrible past especially considering New
Hampshire and it wasn't just putting
them intitution people were sterilized
putting in inhumane conditions granted
we've gotten rid of that and we moved on
but we haven't moved on from the fact
that we criminalized mental
illness thank you very thank you very
much any questions anybody all good all
right seeing no questions thank you very
much is there anybody here wishing to
testify on House Bill 159 that has not
yet turned in a pink card seeing none I
will close the public hearing thank you
all for coming and uh respecting our
three minute time frame I know it's hard
when there is so much to
say
e
e e
guys if you want to take a quick minute
um bio break and then I'll get go gather
up our chairman and then we can come
back in and try to get some of these
bills out so we can get them off our
docket
awesome
e
e e
I'm opening executive session on House
Bill
338 and I recognize myself to make a
motion of inexpedient to
legislate second I'll speak to my motion
this is the bill that is trying to make
our fish and game police officers do
everything um by getting probable cause
before they actually um are able
to investigate to do their job to get
probable cost I think we all heard the
colonel justify and for those of us who
have been here this is like the third or
fourth year this bill has come around
and um frankly it's just not workable
would you like to speak to you for a
second thank you Mr chairman I I just
want to say that um I feel like there is
this Injustice that's trying to be
created uh for others that don't feel
that and I just think it'd be a shame to
um dampen their professional careers and
their livelihoods over someone else's
feeling that's that's a very good point
the the fact that um the people who this
would impact um the fishing industry
came here and begged us to not do it and
leave please leave them alone and I
didn't see one single Hunter who was
here who was engraved as well so um
anyone else would like to speak on that
uh yes chairman Roy yes speaking as a
sea coaster and obviously we're we're
concerned for the welfare of our you
know of our fishing communities as well
and and uh they did not seem to be again
in support um it looks like there's no
need for looks like if if if the bill
was to require a warrant they wouldn't
want that but looks like the bill wasn't
even requesting a warrant also in the
first place
so thank you any further discussion
seeing none I'd ask the court to call
the role the motion on floor is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
338 Vice chair roads yes representative
PR yes representative D Simone yes
representative devoid yes representative
bogert
yes representative pette yes
representative Sabor dhaner yes
representative Matson yes representative
har Gite yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes uh
representative Shear yes chairman royan
chair votes yes 160 160 unanimous any
objection to consent seeing none ofo
consent I hereby close close the
executive session on House Bill 338 I
hereby open the executive session on
House Bill
257 and recognize myself to make a
motion of ought to
pass second seconded by representative F
I'll speak to my motion this is with
regard to the criminal um neglect of a
child um this bill would and what's
interesting is we did hear some
testimony today during the other bill
with regard to how difficult it is to
bring criminal charges against um
parents when comes to cases neglect we
heard from two County attorneys um
requesting that we pass this bill um
because they find it um almost
impossible to bring charges against
parents because of the Dual track system
um and I've spoken with our executive
branch as well and they're interested in
this bill passing it just seems to me
that anything we can do that doesn't um
interfere in the unnecessarily in the in
the parental rights we should and this
allowing the criminal charging for
neglect of a child is very important in
my mind would you like to speak to you a
second no I think you covered it quite
well I appreciate it thank you
discussion representative Sher um I
think as everybody knows uh I oppose
this bill I think to uh I I I am not uh
given my history working in the criminal
legal system I have never been impressed
with the ability of uh Prosecutor's
offices to handle uh issues that are
better handled in inter
interdisciplinary fashion in
organizations like DCF number one number
two the criminal system is less able and
and has less resources available to
manage uh somebody who's convicted of
child neglect in terms of managing the
family managing uh them getting out of a
situation where are causing uh child
abuse um number two number three I think
there is a way and we heard some
significant egregious cases I think
there is a way to deal with more
egregious cases than the law currently
allows for um uh the both County
attorneys testified that the child
endangerment statute has a mental state
of purposely which makes it which is
difficult to prove um I and I have been
very supportive uh and some have agreed
with me that the mental state in that
statute be changed to recklessly which
will bring in
more um more of the uh more egregious
cases without making the county
attorney's office the superintendent of
what is good parenting and what is
neglectful parenting so I'm going to uh
uh oppose this Bill thank you
further represent
Muse I'll be uh regretfully voting uh
against this bill I
I really support uh the intent of what
the sponsor uh is trying to do here but
I think this is a bill that needs uh
some serious work and and I think all of
the issues that representative Sher and
others on the committee raised uh uh
during the hearing some of the issues
that were raised by the Witnesses are
issues that really deserve to be
to be addressed um one of the the
biggest concerns for me was in the
online testimony the uh the office of
the child advocate uh basically weighed
in that it was opposed to the bill as
currently written um these are the
people who are supposed to be looking
after uh the interest of kids probably
more than anybody else in this state um
and to not have them on board with us to
me is a big red flag so um my preference
would be we keep working on it but if
we're not going to keep working on it I
think we should itl it thank you um I I
would say that um and you'll pardon me
for relying on them um representative
Sher but your two former law students
who uh
actually County attorneys now and were
supportive of the bill um and they are
responsible for looking after the
welfare of children with regard to
whether or not they're being criminally
abused or neglected and they both who
have tried numerous cases have said that
this is necessary for them to be able to
to um protect the rights of these
children who have been criminally
negligently harmed so um representative
um shabor shaer something like that
thank you chman Roy what was the the
outcome of the subcommittee what was the
recommendation following the out uh the
recommendation is ought to pass um after
having spoken with all those parties
involved representative Newman
sorry allor right pretty close um I I
just I guess I just wanted to weigh in
because I really wish that I could vote
for this bill um in support of this bill
but I think that it there are certain
considerations that need to be ironed
out and I was hoping that the
subcommittee would do that and so um
yeah I'm really conflicted about it but
I just wanted to I don't know say that
thank you we appreciate it um see you no
further I'd ask the clerk to call the
roll a motion on the is ought to
pass Vice chair roads yes representative
PR yes representative D Simone yes
representative devoid yes representative
bogert yes representative pette yes
representative saborn dwan worth having
a floor vote discussion yes
representative Matson yes sorry yes ma'
representative Harry Gite no
representative muse no representative
Newman no representative
Murphy it's a really tough one for me
and I I
could you know I I wish we could come
back to me but um this is this is really
hard because I I the the intent of this
bill is so good I recognize we need
there are criminal criminal child
neglect
cases oh
God I'm sorry I'm sorry this this
horrible
um okay I'm gonna say
Yes
um the clerk votes yes representative
Newell no representative Shear no
chairman Roy cheral yes 115 115 motion
carries um who will be The Minority
Report I take it representative Sherwood
I will okay and um oh it looks like I
made that motion I'll be writing the
office now I close the public hearing I
hereby open the public hearing on House
Bill 103 I recognize representative
approv for to make a
motion uh
I
103 oh that's because um it was
you hold on stand by
if if I may offer an an apology I got
that bill number confused with the bill
that I did give you and I I take
responsibility for that is my fault um
chairman Roy I I would ask that you give
a professional courtesy for them to have
a few minutes it is houseb 103 and I we
just completely forgot that I made that
mistake the motion was going to be
inexpedient to legislator it is going to
be it they will be making the same
was got a lot of numbers confused today
guys I
apologize and then I tried to fix it
still give the wrong bill number
so it's always two wow I mean you see
this I mean this is
ridiculous are you guys
good yeah
made oh
um uh we're not going to be doing that
one today at all the one I made a
mistake was I gave you
640 and that was the mistake that we are
not doing that today okay all right
where was I all right um represent PR so
I don't get out of having to write that
it was close
rep I'm going to make a motion of
inexpedient to
legislate
second you like to speak to your motion
sure just a little bit my first concern
was crossing out the Constitution of the
United States
uh to me that makes this bill pretty
much
unconstitutional so we as state reps
have an uh a a responsibility not to be
passing unconstitutional bills
so uh and the rest of it it just kind of
muddies the water and yeah uh interferes
with um
yeah you know getting
uh extradition he whiz that W went right
on my
head uh it yeah and we killed about two
Forest today so yeah thank you uh
representative pette would you like to
speak to your
second I agree with what he said wise
decision
um um yes thank you Mr chairman I I
would just like to add that uh
representative PR is exactly right and
as the vice chairman it is actually one
of my rules that is written to our house
our house rules that if a bill is
unconstitutional I we're not supposed to
pass it it's my job to tell everybody
that it is um and actually the
Constitution is stricken from that from
that right in right in the bill that we
can't do that and you know we can't have
it both ways we can't be yelling about
the constitution on one hand and then in
the very the very next hand in the same
body be taken out the Constitution when
it doesn't fit something that we want it
to be um so I appreciate the the
sponsor's intent in his reasoning but
unfortunately I hope that he understands
it's an unconstitutional Bill the way he
wrote
it thank you um seeing no further
discussion I'd ask cour to call the role
motion on the floor is in what who
oh New Hampshire has a proud tradition
of allowing every Bill submitted to have
a public hearing and know it's certainly
okay to have bills come to the floor and
have a hearing this is just one of those
bills where can't go any
further it's okay to have bad
[Laughter]
ideas okay ask clerk to call the role
motion of floor is in expedient to
legisl Vice chair roads yes
representative
PR yes representative D Simone yes
representative devoid yes representative
bogert yes representative pette yes
representative Sabor DW yes
representative Matson yes representative
Harriet gther yes representative Muse
yes representative Newman yes
representative Murphy yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Shear yes chairman Roy
votes yes 160 160 the motion carries in
expedient to legislate any objection to
consent seeing none it will go
consent and one last one uh did everyone
get the amendment I handed out with
regard to um U director
Skippers
yeah if everyone has it I'm going to go
ahead and make a motion then the
amendment number is
0329 does everyone have it okay I open
the executive session on House Bill 778
is that what it is yep
and move um ought to pass an amendment
and I'm offering amendment
number 0329
H thank you I'll speak to the amendment
um director skippa was here and he let
us know that this amendment with regard
to their details just clarifies that
they can only do the details when
they're invited to do so by a local
municipality want to speak to your
second sounds good to me okay very good
um any discussion on Amendment see none
i' ask clerk to call the
rooll it's to adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative PR yes representative D
Simone yes representative devoid yes
representative bogert yes representative
pette yes representative Sabor desonier
yes representative Matson yes
representative Harriet Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Newman yes representative Murphy yes the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative Shear yes chairman
Roy chair votes yes 160 the mo the
amendment is adopted um I make a motion
ought to pass with
amendment seconded by representative
Murray um I'll speak to the motion this
bill as you recall just enables
the uh police officers that work at the
police standards and training Council to
not only do details but Bill for them
from the municipalities currently
they're technically able to as they are
certified Law Enforcement Officers but
they're unable to accept details that
are offered to them because they have no
way of getting renum renumeration
therefore would you like to speak to
your
second I absolutely agree with that um
you know Law Enforcement Officers should
be getting paid um according to the work
that they're doing and this sounds good
to me also a representative Damon I
think had a point of order oh you're all
set further
discussion seeing none asked Court to
call the role motion on the floor is
ought the pass of amendment Vice chair
Ro yes representative PR yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative devoid yes representative
bogert yes representative pette yes
representative saor deir yes
representative Matson yes representative
Harry gther yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Murphy yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell representative
Shear chairman
Roy yes 160
e for